leute habe ich oder grüß gott wieder bayer sagen würde
iq bus abholen easy dark side wolltest du nicht letztens was wegen options und
netz und sowas wissen was du das habe ich das richtige mit der kopf ich habe
sogar ein projekt auf github wo man das sieht wie das einfach funktioniert es
mir eingefallen nach dem letzten stream ich war mal kurz die vm an
das war's du oder ich könnte jetzt in die in den nachrichten historie gucken
aber kannst du einfach mal schreiben ob du das gewesen bist oder nicht
wahrscheinlich ist der inszeniert dann bringe ich durcheinander er wollte
letztens irgendwas wegen options sind dort nicht wissen ganz vergessen keine
ahnung ich kann es ja nachher im stream noch mal ansprechen vielleicht ist ja
derjenige da
so wegen und fick irgendwas mit globaler globalen variablen gefragt denn dort
nicht weiß nicht mehr wer das war ich finde den typ ja cool aber die
fangen mich trotzdem ab mit ihrem gestreike aber wisst ihr wisst ihr dass
der stream indirekt gesponsert ist von der gdl drum dann gespielt ab weil ohne
die gdl hätte ich morgen fünf vor fünf
fünfundvierzig aufstehen müssen um nach frankfurt zu fahren und dank gdl und
streik kann ich home office machen also jetzt sehe ich finde das auf twitter
immer so lustig wenn ich mir das angucke so du hast du hast einmal die leute so
nach dem motto alter die streiken ja mehr als sie arbeiten wie kann das denn sein
blablabla so und da gibt es die anderen die sagen
so ja mein vollste solidarität und support und ich hänge da irgendwo dazwischen und denkt mir
so ihr dürft das aber ich finde trotzdem scheiße und mir geht es am arsch vorbei ja ich bin immer
dafür für vier tage woche und verdient mehr geld aber eigentlich geht es mir alles am arsch vorbei
ich will einfach nur dass mich das nicht unnötig in meinem leben einschränkt das weshalb und warum
und sonst was ist mir komplett egal soll einfach funktionieren die infrastruktur machst du nicht
sowieso viel home office doch aber morgen nicht selbst wenn es doch wie gesagt ich mache einen tag
also ich mache von meiner vier tage woche war ich drei tage home office und ein tag fahre ich nach
frankfurt und morgen würde ich nach frankfurt fahren aber dank gdl muss ich morgen nicht nach
frankfurt fahren
ich habe morgen nämlich also morgen hätte ich tatsächlich gemusst oder es wäre schon sehr
sinnvoll gewesen weil ich habe alle 14 tage mit meinem chef so einen austausch termin wie auch
immer das wie nennt sich das offiziell ich muss mal kurz gucken das hat bestimmt irgendeinen coolen
irgendeinen coolen namen wie heißt das teamskalender morgen okay das heißt einfach nur max
der termin ist einfach nur max
gut aggressiv juego
ach ziel angesltrygen namen prof dr ente pox abskrybt des leute hier hatte
jetzt gemacht ja also deswegen normalerweise hätte ich morgen 45 aufstehen müssen da sie rechtzeitig
nach frankfurt komme weil 37 geht es ja gehts los muss ich etwas machen und das muss ich jetzt dank
der gdl nicht machen
Ich mach mal kurz Package Updates
Ist derjenige da, der letztens mich gefragt hat
Nach globalen Variablen in .NET
Hört sich nach einem Win an
Ja, könnte man so sagen
Kann man eigentlich
Wenn man ein Deutschland Ticket hat
Also 49 Euro Ticket
Kann man das eigentlich anteilig
Sich erstatten lassen, wenn gestreikt wird
Du hast doch ein Auto, weißt das
Doch, doch, das weiß der
Also gut, ob der das so genau noch weiß
Weiß ich nicht, also der weiß das
Weil ich hab sogar im Vorstellungsgespräch
Aber da war ein anderer dabei
Da war das noch gar nicht mein Chef
Also das hat sich alles ein bisschen geändert
Da hab ich den Fiat Champ
Sogar im Vorstellungsgespräch
Erwähnt
Weil ich hatte mein GitHub Account
Im Lebenslauf
In meinem Skillsheet
Da mit drin stehen
Und anscheinend haben die da wirklich geguckt
Da hab ich auch erzählt, Elektroauto
Und Integration und so, programmiert
Doch, doch, die wissen das
Aber ich fahr
Kein Auto
Außer es muss sein
Ah, geht schon los
Ja Leute, wenn ihr irgendwas habt
Was ich mir da angucken soll
Dann schickt rüber
Ich werde jetzt noch ein bisschen schwätzen
Und dann legen wir los
KDE Plasma 6
Ganz ehrlich, ich find alle Oberflächen
Unter Linux kacke, außer i3
Und i3 auch nur
Weil i3 so minimalistisch ist
Dass es einfach nix hat, was dir irgendwie auf den Sack kommt
Und das ist auch so, dass es einfach nix hat, was dir irgendwie auf den Sack kommt
Deutsche Bahn verhelfen, wenn sie mit ihrem Deutschland-Ticket unterwegs sind
Und aufgrund einer Verspätung im Nahverkehr
Mindestens 60 Minuten Verspätung annehmen
60 Minuten, Alter!
Geil! Das lohnt sich aber mal richtig
Meine normale Fahrzeit ist 45 Minuten
Mobile Flutter Entwickler
Ja, ja, ja
Svove, hab ich ja noch nie gehört
Svove
Also ich mag, ich mag i3 als einziges
kein Gnome oder
Gnome oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht.
Ich mag kein KDE.
Ich mag kein
Was gibt es da sonst noch? LXDE?
LXQT?
Mate?
Oder sonst was?
Weißt du, das kann ich nicht ausprobieren,
weil das in der VM nicht gescheit funktioniert.
Ja, also
ganz im Ernst, wenn es ein Desktop sein muss,
dann, also Cinnamon, gerade in
Verbindung mit Mint, finde ich noch ganz erträglich.
Und
wenn es irgendwie
besonders minimalistisch sein muss, XFCE
auch vielleicht noch.
Was auch noch geht, ist sowas wie Fluxbox
oder so in der Richtung, aber
ganz ehrlich, eigentlich finde ich alles kacke.
Ich finde alles kacke, außer E3.
Und vielleicht, wenn
Wayland funktionieren würde,
wenn Wayland funktionieren
würde ordentlich in der VM,
dann würde ich
vielleicht auch Sway verwenden, aber Wayland
funktioniert nicht gescheit in der VM.
Aber Plasma,
Plasma 6 ist ganz neu, gell?
Razer, danke schön für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscriptions hier heute.
IIQ-Chat wieder am Start, ich seh's schon.
Leute, ich bin ziemlich kaputt.
Ich bin vorhin zweieinhalb Stunden Fahrrad gefahren.
Ich bin jetzt, so ihr vorsteht,
Fahrrad kam am Freitag.
Ich bin Freitag Probe gefahren,
ein bisschen über eine Stunde.
Samstag
eine Runde gefahren.
Sonntag 7,5 Kilometer
gerannt und heute
zweieinhalb Stunden gefahren.
Also, ich glaube, ich habe noch nie so viel Sport am Stück gemacht.
Kennt jemand eine gute App,
um GPS, also GPX-Routen
zu animieren, zu visualisieren?
Also, ihr kennt das doch zum Beispiel,
wenn ihr so Tour de France Intro habt,
so von der heutigen Etappe,
wo die dann so durchfliegen und man so die Profile der Anstiege sieht
und dann, dann, dann schwenkt das so rüber
und dann sieht man, okay, hier ist dieser Wegpunkt.
Dann fliegt das so über eine Map drüber.
Kennt ihr, kennt, kennt ihr?
Irgendwas, irgendeine App, wo man easy aus dem
GPX-File, wo man halt sein, seine
Tour aufgezeichnet hat, sowas
generieren kann?
Ja, einfach schnell googeln kann ich auch.
Am besten, am besten für iOS.
Also, am liebsten muss ich da gar nicht
an PC für, kann das
direkt aus Komoot machen, irgendwie öffnen.
Ich fahre nach, also mit dem
Fahrrad fahre ich in der Möglichkeit immer was anderes.
Ich meine, es gibt auch nur eine
beschränkte Anzahl, was man fahren kann.
Leute,
heute war ich so, war ich so im Arsch,
ich hab
bisschen, bisschen verpeilt, ja.
Ich hab Komoot Strecke geplant,
dachte mir so, ah, okay,
passt schon, irgendwie 32 Kilometer,
kein Ding.
Und, dann ist mir
aufgefallen, da sind
vier Berge drinne, also Berge,
ne, da lachen sich die Schweizer wieder kaputt.
Da sind
vier Berge drin und der eine
geht bis zu 12%
über
einen Kilometer.
Also, er geht nicht 12% einen Kilometer lang,
aber er geht bis zu 12%
über einen Kilometer lang.
Und, im Durchschnitt ist er, glaube ich,
irgendwie sieben oder so. Alter, Leute,
ich sag euch, ich, ich, ich
bin komplett Dettke gewesen.
Ich sag ohne Scheiß,
sieben Prozent im Durchschnitt
ist schon nicht ohne.
Aber,
mit, mit
zwölf Prozent zwischenzeitlich
drinne, ey, ich, ich hab so geschnauft,
also, aber ich, ich bin nicht, also, ich musste im Vergleich zum letzten Mal, muss ich nicht absteigen.
Letztes Mal bin ich ja auch einen Berg hochgefahren.
Letzte größere Runde,
das wäre aber noch ein bisschen länger, da muss ich dann absteigen irgendwann.
Ausruhen, aber das ging.
Es ist aber richtig nice,
also, man merkt, dass diese Home-Trainer-Sache
im Winter sich gelohnt hat.
Man, man merkt jetzt,
dass man viel mehr Kraft in den Beinen hat.
Wie viel Höhenmeter pro Strecke, um, um die
400 waren's heute.
Oder, warte mal, warte mal, kann ich dir sagen,
äh,
wo ist denn, Moment, falsches Handy.
Keck, wait.
Äh,
wo hab ich denn
Komoot am Start?
Hier, Höhenmeter
390.
Es war ein
größerer Berg und drei kleine.
Nein, ich bin, ich bin noch erst seit
zehn Minuten on.
So, ich wollte erst mal Package-Updates
machen. Hab ich jetzt eigentlich alle geupdatet?
Ich glaub schon.
Guck mal mal.
Ob's bei JetBrains was Neues gibt?
Nee, gibt's nicht. Okay.
Reboot.
Was meinst du? Fahrrad?
Das ist fast das Gleiche wie vorher, ja.
Aha.
Relocate.me
Bei Amazon.
Naja, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen,
muss man sagen, ähm,
außerhalb dem,
was die meisten Leute sich so vorstellen.
Arch, by the way.
Jawoll.
Excellent.
Chat, letzte Chance.
Ist derjenige am Start heute,
der mich gefragt hat gestern zu
.net globale Variablen?
Falls ja, kann ich kurz was zeigen.
Wisst ihr, was mich heute wieder gestört hat?
Im Wald.
Dass manche Gassigeher
es einfach nicht auf die Reihe kriegen,
ihren Hund an die Leine zu nehmen
oder den Hund ans Halsband zu nehmen
neben sich, wenn du da mit dem Fahrrad
vorbeifährst. Viele Waldwege sind jetzt
nicht super breit und
...
Da hast du immer so ein bisschen mulmiges Gefühl,
dass der Hund jetzt jederzeit nach dir springen könnte.
Das ist eh das, äh,
die Herrchen sind eigentlich immer das Schlimmste.
Hunde können da dann wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal
großartig was für.
Ah, das ist immer echt ätzend.
Zumal ich auf dem Fahrrad meinen Pfefferspray nicht dabei hab.
Es geht eh so schnell, da kannste das nicht zücken.
Claymore.
Pfefferspray Claymore.
Einfach hinsetzt auf den Weg.
So.
Updates sind, Updates sind durch.
Die Stellanzeige für mein Nachfolger ist live.
Nice, schick her.
Da können wir uns,
also je nachdem wie die geschrieben ist,
ein bisschen drüber lustig machen.
Oder aber,
was pro Samen,
ach nee, pro Samed,
was so ein Buchstaben
ausmachen kann, Alter.
Was machen die denn?
Kennt man die? Ähm, und ich hab
nochmal eine Frage an auch
die Fahrrad-Enjoyer unter euch.
Vielleicht haben wir da welche.
Was, was sagt ihr?
Kette wachsen oder nicht
Kette wachsen?
Das ist keine Anspielung auf irgendwas.
Ich meine das wörtlich.
Was, was ist hier mit den
BTFS-Volumes los, Chat?
Was snap,
was, was snapshottet ihr euch hier
ein ab? Muss flutschen,
denke ich auch, ja.
Das, was der Hersteller empfiehlt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die überhaupt irgendwas
empfehlen.
Ich finde die, die
Idee dahinter gar nicht, gar nicht
mal so, gar nicht mal so blöd,
dass du halt immer einen komplett fettfreien
Antrieb hast,
easy Kette abmachen kannst,
ohne dass du
dreckige Hände kriegst, einfach mit Wasser das ganze
Fahrrad abspülen, ohne da dich irgendwie um
Maintenance großartig zu kümmern,
außer ab und zu mal
Kette nachwachsen.
Mal gucken. Weil das Ding ist,
das Ding ist,
ich werde eh meine Kassette
tauschen und die Kette, also
ist das schon recht sauber?
Hast du dir schon
Apple-Pückel angeguckt? Nein, das ist
das ist das Apple-Jason, oder?
Das habe ich mal in irgendeinem News gelesen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich ein Jason-Konkurrent
überhaupt ist.
Aber habe ich mir noch nicht angeguckt.
Ja, also ich habe heute echt wieder gemerkt,
als ich da
die 12% Steigung hoch
bin,
dass ich doch noch ein bisschen mehr,
wie nennt man das,
Bandbreite
brauche, was meine Schaltung angeht.
Weil, ey,
es ist echt schon,
da
kriege ich noch nicht genug Watt aus den Beinen raus,
dass ich das easy da hochfahren kann.
Ja, es ist eigentlich, ich habe
mich da ein bisschen schlauer gemacht, es ist eigentlich
relativ easy. Man muss einmal alles schön entfetten,
nein, jetzt, mittlerweile habe ich zwei
vorne.
Das alte hatte nur eins, das alte hatte nur eins.
Aber ich habe eine elektronische Schaltung
mit Synchro-Shift, das ist mega nice.
Ich schalte auch nur hoch und runter
und das Umwerfen vorne macht er automatisch.
Synchro-Shift,
ja, das heißt so.
Okay,
Di2 Synchro-Shift.
Ja, so funzt das. Es gibt sogar,
es gibt sogar eine App für.
Aber echt, das ist wirklich dann die Wissenschaft für sich.
Das klingt
was aus Yu-Gi-Oh! Ja, stimmt schon.
Musst du erstmal opfern.
Ja, das ist dann echt die Wissenschaft für sich.
An sich ist das, ist das
mega nice. Du musst dich gar nicht mehr drum
kümmern, dass vorne geschaltet wird.
Ja, also an sich ist es einfach, man muss alles entfetten
und
dann ein bisschen
Wachs drauf tröpfeln. Was eine Wissenschaft
für sich ist, ist
heiß wachsen.
Mit Herdplatte und
und allem. Das ist mir dann aber auch fast schon
zu viel, das ist gut.
Trinkst du Sportshakes? Nein.
Ich trink außer Wasser und Tee nichts.
Ich trink keine Fanta.
Keine Cola.
Oder
oder irgendwie Kaffee
oder so. Ich trink nur Wasser
und Tee. Ich
ich fress genug. Ich hab
mehr als genug
ja, Zeug zum
Muskelaufbau.
Kein Kaffee, nee. Das ist jetzt doppelt
geil eigentlich mit kein Kaffee, weil
ich bin gefühlt der einzige ITler,
der kein Kaffee trinkt und
bei den ganzen Fahrradfahrern ist
Kaffee auch so eine Religion.
Ich bin jetzt
da doppelt weird champ.
Zumindest war ich heute froh, dass ich was zu
trinken dabei hatte.
So, dann legen wir mal los. Du trinkst auch
kein Kaffee.
Wir sind nicht allein, es gibt noch genug.
Das mach ich nicht.
Es gab Spinatnudeln, was gab's
bei dir? Ah, super
gesunde Sachen gab's bei mir heute.
Äh,
Pommes Frites, Mozzarella Sticks
mit Mayonnaise dabei.
Gesündestes Essen
überhaupt. Also ich bin
ich werde dieses Jahr 40
und ich hab bis jetzt noch nicht mit Kaffee angefangen.
Mozzarella Sticks, das ist so
paniert. Von dem Mozzarella schmeckst du eh nix.
Nee, nee, nee, das, wobei das stimmt
auch nicht. Mozzarella Sticks, da ist so
ne komische Dipsoße dabei, aber
aber Mayonnaise für die
für die Pommes Frites. Heute
kam 4K OLED 240
Hertz, 31,5.
Also außer, dass ich mir ein 31,5
Zoll bei meinem Sitzabstand viel zu groß wär,
der Rest ist natürlich extremly nice.
Hat der auch nen Lüfter?
Oder kommt der ohne
Lüfter aus?
Ja, ist aber so. Ich trink
nur Wasser und Tee.
So. Ja, dann fangen wir
doch mal an, würd ich sagen.
Erstmal husten.
Wann hust champ?
Eine Runde Astriquarium
zur Entspannung, bevor's losgeht.
So. Also mit was fangen wir
an? Ich würd sagen
ProSamed.
Das müssen wir hier
aber mal ganz schnell
rüberpasten,
weil
eindeutig zu hell.
Okay. ProSamed.
Ich muss erstmal gucken, was das ist.
Not now.
Das innovative Netzwerk
für Gesundheit. Wir stehen für eine ganzheitliche
Versorgung aus... Das ist quasi so ne Art
Apotheke oder sowas?
Ja. Sowas in der
Richtung. Okay, Berlin.
Da sind die eh schon mal
lost, ey. Aha.
Okay. Also, was wollen sie denn haben?
Die suchen einen IT Administrator.
Einen, nein, einen IT System
Administrator suchen sie.
Einen permanent
Employee. Fulltime in Berlin.
Aha. Also eine Festanstellung.
Sozusagen.
Instant Berlin Flame.
Ich war nur einmal in meinem Leben
in Berlin.
Muss grad überlegen, ob das stimmt.
Ähm...
Und...
Das hat mir nicht gefallen.
Ich habe keine...
Kein Verlangen, da wieder hinzugehen.
Da fand ich München tatsächlich
nicer. Wenn sie mich da auch
nicht wirklich hinzieht wieder.
Du wechselst von Leipzig nach Berlin.
Jeder, worauf er Bock hat.
München ist sehr nice. Vor allem ist
München, glaube ich, sehr nice.
Teuer.
Hamburg war ich tatsächlich schon öfter.
Hamburg hab ich mal...
Das erste Mal, wo ich in Hamburg war,
hab ich ein
MMO Grill besucht.
Frag mich nicht. 2004 oder so.
Das lief aber nicht so gut.
Das erste Mal in Hamburg.
Naja. So, also.
Was wollen sie denn haben?
War die...
Schwer zu sagen. Also...
Das war super weird.
Also...
Wenn man sich nur online kennt
und ein paar Mal telefoniert hat
und sich RL sieht, da merkt man meistens
relativ schnell, ob man sich so
gegenseitig nice
findet oder nicht.
Und wir fanden uns gegenseitig
nicht so nice.
Pech gehabt, ja.
arrowchild26
Es kam kein
Vibe auf. Das trifft es
eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Manchmal sind Jugendworte
doch sehr nice.
Ja, es ist ein Unterschied, ob man sich aus dem Game kennt
und ein bisschen telefoniert, auch weiß, wie die anderen aussehen
und so. Aber wenn man sich dann RL trifft,
das ist ein Unterschied.
Es kam kein Vibe auf.
Das trifft es wirklich gut, ja.
Ich bin am gleichen Tag auch wieder
heimgefahren.
Dann bin ich mitten in der Nacht angekommen
am Bahnhof und dann ist kein Bus mehr gefahren.
Jedenfalls hatte man noch kein Handy,
kein Smartphone, um irgendwas nachzugucken.
Vom Hauptbahnhof bin ich
heimgelaufen, mitten in der Nacht.
Hat sich so überhaupt nicht gelohnt.
Nun gut, also, was will
prosamed haben?
Also, immer noch ein IT System
Administrator. Was bieten?
Übrigens, Leute, falls ihr irgendwas habt,
was ich mal angucken soll,
schickt her.
Ansonsten suche ich nachher bei den üblichen Verdächtigen
nochmal ein bisschen was, was mich
ansprechen soll.
Ich suche keinen Job.
Gibt es die Story schon in voller Länge
im Archiv, Max?
Ne, ich glaube nicht.
Aber viel mehr gibt es dazu auch nicht zu erzählen.
Oder wahrscheinlich
habe ich das auch schon mal kurz.
Viel mehr gibt es da echt nicht zu erzählen.
Das einzige, was ich noch weiß, ist, dass sie Kim hieß.
Und blonde, kurze Haare hatte.
Ansonsten
ein Piercing in der Nase
hatte sie. Das kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern,
weil es war so dunkel.
Aber ansonsten, ich habe keine Ahnung mehr,
wie die ausgeschaut hat, was die gemacht hat.
Kein Plan.
Kim.com
Genau.
Steinhardler fünf Tage vor den Zapf.
Aber ansonsten
keine Ahnung mehr.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal,
was sie in dem Game gespielt hat, überhaupt.
Das war bestimmt er.
Das sah dem...
Dann hat er sich aber stark gewandelt
seitdem.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß da kaum noch was von.
Ich meine, das war 2004
oder so. Das ist schon ewig her.
Ja, sind wir, sind wir.
Hot Cheesecake.
Ansonsten weiß ich da echt gar nichts mehr.
Aber es kam eh kein Vibe auf,
wie ihr schon festgestellt habt.
Ja, Ero Child schickt rüber,
wenn ich mir was angucken soll.
Kann sein, dass ich irgendwas übersehen habe,
aber ich glaube nicht.
Also, gucken wir uns jetzt hier
ProSamed an.
Also, wir bieten...
Was ich schon mal gut finde an der Stellenanzeige,
sie fangen nicht an mit
wir sind führender
Dienstleister im Bereich XY.
Allerdings muss ich
ehrlich sagen, vielleicht
sagen wir mal so,
einen Satz
zu der Firma könnte man vielleicht
schreiben. Ich weiß nicht jeder, wer ProSamed ist.
Aber finde ich
schon mal gut, dass nicht erst irgendwie
ein halber Roman Selbstbeweihräucherung kommt.
Okay.
Gehaltsentwicklung und Rahmenbedingungen entsprechen
Apotheken-Tarifvertrag.
Da weiß ich nicht, ob das gut oder schlecht ist.
Tarifvertrag ist prinzipiell eigentlich immer ganz gut.
Ob das...
Ob der
was taugt und welche
Stufe man in diesem Tarifvertrag bekommt,
da gibt es sicherlich auch unterschiedliche...
Was ist das für eine Webseite,
Alter? Oder liegt das
an meinem Darkreader?
Ne, das liegt noch nicht an meinem Darkreader.
Das ist einfach broken as fuck.
Das kann man immer markieren.
Die brauchen ganz dringend einen Anwendungsentwickler, ja?
The fuck?
Okay, die Webseite ist wirklich
kacke.
Zumal du uns jetzt nicht mal anklicken kannst.
Du kannst ja nichts als PDF
exportieren kannst.
Okay.
Aber ist nicht so sehr...
So, also lass mal hier angucken.
Äh, Apotheken-Tarifvertrag.
Okay, das kommt auf die Stufe an,
aber erstes Mal ist Tarifvertrag nicht verkehrt.
Betriebliche
Altersvorsorge, Arbeitgeberanteil
plus 20% auf die
Eigenumwandlung. Ist immer nice, wenn sowas
angeboten wird.
28 Ta...
Das ist noch ein bisschen wenig.
Monatlicher Sachgutschein im Wert von 50 Euro.
Netto.
Bezahlt ein ordentliches Gehalt,
dann erübtrigt sich das
Problem, ja?
Elektronische Arbeitszeiterfassung. Moment, das ist
eine, wir bieten. Jede Minute zählt und kann
gebummelt oder ausge...
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das so ein Vorteil ist,
Arbeitszeiterfassung ist doch sogar Pflicht mittlerweile.
Also das ist, das ist ja
okay, nice, aber
ist das jetzt so ein
krasser Vorteil, was man unter wir bieten?
Okay, äh, viele
Möglichkeiten der beruflichen Weiterbildung,
okay. Mitarbeiterrabatte in unseren
Apotheken... Ja gut.
Wenn man das braucht.
Ist wahrscheinlich nicht verkehrt.
Ein individuelles Einarbeitungskonzept ohne
Zeitdruck mit Platz für Fragen und Antworten.
Das, ich sag's jedes Mal,
ich weiß, es ist gut gemeint, dass sie das
reinschreiben, aber ich bin halt immer der Meinung,
Einarbeitung ist so, dass
es liegt so im ureigensten Interesse
der Firma, dich einzuarbeiten, dass du was machen kannst
für dein Geld.
Ja, auch wenn es witzigerweise bei vielen nicht
funktioniert.
Aber eigentlich sollte das
das ureigenste Interesse der Firma sein,
die neuen Leute ordentlich einzuarbeiten.
Und bunte Teams, kompetent,
gut eingespielt und
durch Zusammenhalt geprägt.
Weirdchamp.
Zentrale Lage,
Nähe S-Bahn.
Okay, das ist natürlich gut.
Wenn man, wenn es eine gute Anbindung hat
und wenn es Parkmöglichkeiten gibt,
das ist tatsächlich ein Vorteil.
Ein familienfreundliches Umfeld inklusive Kinderspielzimmer
mit Elternarbeitsplatz.
Für Leute, die sowas brauchen,
ist das sicherlich sehr nice.
Bei mir auf der Arbeit gibt's auch
einen Kindergarten.
Rückenkurs.
Pilates und Massagen
vor Ort zu vergünstigten Konditionen.
Why not?
Es gibt einen ganzen Kindergarten, ja.
Ey, wir sind eine
riesen Versicherung in Frankfurt.
Frag mich nicht,
wie viele tausend Mitarbeiter oder so.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele wir insgesamt haben.
Da gibt's genug Leute mit Kinder
und die finden das mega, dass wir einen eigenen Kindergarten haben.
Regelmäßige Events.
Zum Beispiel Sommerfest mit Barbecue.
Große Weihnachtsfeier oder Teamessen.
Ist für mich schon mal kein Vorteil.
Ist für mich eher nervig.
Sucht nach einer Versicherung in Frankfurt
mit Kindergarten. Let's go.
Das Mitwirken in einem
Sucht, wenn ihr wollt.
Das Mitwirken
in einem inhabergeführten Familienunternehmen
mit liebenswerten Traditionen
und einem wertschätzenden Klima.
Wie toll das ist, zeigt sich erst,
wenn man da ist.
Bitte beachten Sie, dass wir nur Kandidaten
in unserem Auswahlverfahren sind,
die bereits eine Arbeitserlaubnis besitzen.
Gut, das ist natürlich sinnvoll.
Aufgaben und Tätigkeiten.
Okay, jetzt geht's los.
Jetzt kommt die Einleitung,
wer Sie sind.
Vielleicht bin ich falsch rum?
Im Herzen Berlins
versorgt das ProSame-Netzwerk für...
Okay, bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Das überdurchschnittliche
Wachstum des Netzwerks
wird begleitet
von einer kontinuierlichen Anpassung
der EDV-Infrastruktur und Prozesse.
Zur Unterstützung der damit verbunden Projekte
suchen wir zum nächstmöglichen Zeitpunkt
einen Systemadministrator MWD,
der Lust auf diese Reise hat.
Aber Hauptsache EDV.
Sie sorgen dafür,
dass die Netzwerkinfrastruktur
stabil ist und läuft.
Sucht ihr nicht eher
einen Netzwerkadministrator dann?
Systemadministrator ist für mich
jetzt zwar auch durchaus Netzwerk,
aber nicht hauptsächlich
Netzwerk.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Die Anwender in den Fachabteilungen sind happy,
weil sie ihn im Rahmen eines
FIRST LEVEL SUPPORTS bei Frank...
Jetzt ist vorbei bei mir.
Keck bei.
Da hätte ich ja gar keinen Bock drauf.
Sie kümmern sich um
die Administration und bieten Second Level Support
im Bereich der Serversysteme und Firmennetzwerke.
Ja, Moment jetzt.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Okay, du machst Endanwender-Support,
das Spiel für meinen Drucker funktioniert nicht.
Und dann musst du dich natürlich
auch noch mit Servern
und Netzwerk und so gut auskennen,
dass du den Rest machen kannst.
Du machst einfach
Full-Stack-Administrator.
Du machst alles.
Sie meistern Installation,
Konfiguration, Optimierung,
Monitoring, Patch-Management,
Troubleshooting von Windows
beziehungsweise...
Was soll
beziehungsweise an der Stelle heißen?
Es sind Windows
und Linux Server,
beziehungsweise
in virtuellen Umgebungen
VMware, vSphere.
Das kann man nicht ohne, ja.
Sie bringen sich aktiv
in Projekte zur Konzeption
und Optimierung der IT-Infrastruktur
für die Steuerung und Koordination
externer Dienstleister ein.
Sie bringen sich aktiv in Projekte
zur Optimierung der IT-Infrastruktur
für die Steuerung...
Die haben beispielsweise
irgendeinen Provider,
der für sie die Internetanbindung macht
und haben vielleicht irgendeinen,
der die Webseite betreut
oder was auch immer
und die sollst du dann quasi noch
ordentlich einplanen, oder wie?
Durch ihre Teilnahme
an der Rufbereitschaft
sichert sie sich
kontinuierlichen Assetbetrieb.
Wait a minute.
Vielleicht sollten wir mal
umgedreht fragen.
Du machst
First Level End Anwender Support,
du machst Netzwerk,
Server,
Virtualisierung, Monitoring,
Projekte
und
koordinierst irgendwelche externen
Dienstleister und du machst
die Rufbereitschaft dafür.
Eigentlich gibt es nichts, was du nicht machst, oder?
Also was zu diesem...
was dazu gehört.
Ich meine, du machst jetzt nicht
die Tür morgens auf und so,
wobei, man weiß es ja nicht.
Und dann auch nur
28 Tage Urlaub?
Also das scheint mir doch wieder,
wir suchen eine IT-Abteilung in einer Person zu sein.
Ich muss aber nochmal dazu sagen,
Stellenanzeigen sind
immer der erste Eindruck, den wir bekommen
von einem Unternehmen.
Das heißt noch lange nicht, dass der Laden wirklich schlecht ist
oder so.
Aber wir können das ja nur anhand der Stellenanzeige beurteilen.
Genauso wie die das nur anhand
unserer Bewerbung
und was wir da so reinschreiben.
Oder das aber dem ersten Kontakt mit uns
beurteilen können.
Und das ja auch machen.
Und so müssen wir das mit der Stellenanzeige auch handhaben.
Also es kann sein, dass der Laden wirklich gut ist und was taugt.
Für mich sieht die Stellenanzeige allerdings nicht so aus,
als würde ich da arbeiten wollen.
Also ich suche eh nichts neues, aber sieht auch nicht so aus.
Es kann natürlich auch sein,
dass der Laden noch schlimmer ist, als man denkt.
Ja, es ist nichts, ist da ausgeschlossen.
Kompetenzen und Talente.
Okay, es geht noch weiter.
Abgeschlossen, okay, das übliche.
Mindestens 3 Jahre aktive Berufserfahrung.
Wünschenswerte Kenntnisse.
Mikrofokus Open Enterprise Server 24.
Okay.
Was ist Mikrofokus Open Enterprise Server 24?
Der Name klingt schon so Business Enterprise.
Okay, das ist ganz harte Business Enterprise Software.
Da hätte ich ja wenig Bock.
What?
Mikrofokus Groupwise Workgroup Suite.
Der Name hat 7 Еще.
Der Name hat 7 еще.
Mikrofokus Groupwise Workshop.
Mikeigene zu werden,
Sie meiner Nummer.
Ja, da slipping idiot.
Sunworks Configuration Management columns.
Ja, das sieht auf nicht gut aus.
Ich will keine Inhalts nouveau.
Aber die haben die auch super auswendig.
Ach Moment, das ist auch ein Mikrofon. Die haben doch super exotisches Zeug am Start, oder?
Novell. Alter, was für Oldschool-Shit ist hier am Start?
Das ist ein Name, den habe ich schon seit 20 Jahren nicht mehr gehört.
Ach, ich habe das übrigens verwechselt mit Zendesk. Zendesk ist die Ticketsystem.
Virtualisierungslösung.
Unter VMware ESX, Moment, VMware ESX ist die Virtualisierungslösung.
Windows Server 2012, 2016, 2022, Windows 10, Windows 11.
Insgeheim bin ich ja krasser Windows-Kenner, nachdem wir uns das einmal im Stream angeguckt haben.
Ich bin ja durchgedreht bei, mit diesem komischen Windows, wie heißt das Ding?
Windows Server Konfigurationsmanager oder sowas.
Setup-Manager rumhantieren musste, das war ganz grausam.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das jemand freiwillig hauptberuflich machen kann.
Betriebssystem Software Linux?
Suse!
Was ist das für ein... was ist das?
Feuer, bam. Moment, fuck!
Der geht in die Bounce rein!
Los!
Voll!
Ja, WSL hat nicht so gut funktioniert unter Windows Server, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Das stört Windows komplett.
Ja.
Naja, habe ich aus Versehen an Windows gelöscht halt.
War auch, gab, gibt Schlimmeres.
Da ist es wenigstens weg.
Okay.
Suse Linux Enterprise, Ubuntu Server CentOS.
CentOS benutzt keiner mehr.
Es sei denn, sie haben noch CentOS 7.
Und das sollte man jetzt schleunigst loswerden.
Radiant Tracer, danke schön für den Sub.
So, ich muss mal kurz gucken, nicht, dass ich wieder irgendwas vergessen habe hier.
Stream Manager.
Steiner Adler hat auch subscribed.
Danke schön.
Bin ich sicher, ob ich es übersehen habe.
Oder bin mir auch nicht sicher, ob ich es gesehen habe.
Also.
Vernetzungsstrukturen via VPN.
Das sind aber besonders Deutsch-Enjoyer, oder?
Was soll das überhaupt bedeuten, ne?
Mindestens C1 Deutschkenntnisse, offene Augen und Ohren für Nutzerbedürfnisse und die Fähigkeit, Sachverhalte zu erfassen und Lösungen zu erarbeiten.
Ausgeprägte Dienst-Leistungs- und Kundenorientierung.
Engagiertes Auftreten sowie Verantwortungsbewusstsein.
Das kommt alles mit der passenden Bezahlung.
Analytisches und planerisches Denken.
Selbstständigkeit beim Erkennen und Lösung von IT-Problemen.
Führerscheinklasse B wünschenswert.
Wann kann es losgehen?
Zum nächstmöglichen Zeitpunkt.
Interesse. Unten klicken.
Expected Salary.
Oh, wie viele Genders gibt es denn zur Auswahl?
Undi-Find.
Ja, gut.
Schwer einzuschätzen.
Ob die taugen oder nicht.
Wir gucken uns jetzt die an, weil mich die Webseite schon so fertig macht, wenn ich mir die angucke.
Also, die brauchen dringend einen Webdesigner.
Das sieht grausam aus.
Und das liegt nicht an meinem Darkreader.
Die Webseite sieht normalerweise auch so kaputt aus.
Deutsch C1 muss man in Berlin schon erwähnen.
Und da könntest du recht haben, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, was C1 bedeutet.
Das sind...
Also, ich kenn das.
Das gibt da so verschiedene Stufen.
Das steht auch bei Englisch auch immer.
Vielleicht liegt es am Browser.
Meinst du?
Meinst du, das sind...
Chrome?
Nee, ist auch nicht besser.
Guck mal, wie es in Firefox aussieht.
Da würden sie ja bei mir Pluspunkte sammeln.
Nee, Firefox ist auch kaputt.
Was steht denn auf dem Logo?
Äh, das sind Einsen und Nullen hier.
Wir sind...
Dienstplan?
Steht da?
Wir sind Dienstplan?
Wir sind Dienstplan-Lan.
Warum ist das Logo übernimmt?
Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Warum kann man den Text nicht markieren?
Warum kann man nicht rechtsklicken auf der Seite?
Was ist das?
Was ist das für eine Webseite, Mann?
Wir akzeptieren jetzt die Cookies.
Okay, wir sind Dienstplan.
Ah, die bieten ja irgendeine Zeiterfassungssoftware oder so an.
Also...
Ich mach jetzt mal den Darkreader aus, ja.
So sieht die Webseite ja gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Coole Animationen haben sie ja am Start.
Also...
Cool.
Man hat's versucht.
Schön ist sie nicht.
Produkte.
Ja, die bieten Zeiterfassungssoftware an.
Die ein bisschen aussieht wie...
So olle...
Alter!
The fuck?
Das sind...
Das sind Dings?
Das sind GTK?
Die alten GTK-Icons?
Das ist ne...
Sag mal, ist das ne olle Windows-Forms-Anwendung?
Die sieht schon richtig oldschool aus.
Wer kauft sich denn freiwillig sowas, Mann?
Das sieht aus straight 1998.
Dass es nicht webbasiert ist, sondern ne Windows-Client braucht, ist ja schon mal grausam.
Es geht einfach mal ein Video los.
Weil du auf der Seite runterscrollst, Mann.
Was ist das für ne Webseite, Mann?
Weiß ich nicht, da ging eben einfach...
Hier!
Guck mal!
Noch nicht mal richtig skaliert ist das Ding auf dem Handy, Alter!
Das ist nicht mal richtig skaliert auf dem Handy!
Das ist nicht...
Das haben die auf dem Desktop aufgenommen und dann wahrscheinlich nachbearbeitet auf so ein Handy gemacht.
Boah, das...
Also...
Es kann sein, dass die Firma super ist, aber das wirkt echt ein bisschen gewollt und nicht gekonnt.
Wie ist denn der Dienstplan?
Was kostet denn der Kram so?
Achso, darf man nicht sehen.
Ja gut.
Alter!
Alter, die Webseite, die macht mich fertig!
Und was kostet's?
Weiß man nicht.
Gibt's erst, nachdem dir das Sales-Team drei Stunden das Ohr abgekaut hat, erfährst du, was es kostet.
Okay, drei Votes.
Drei Votes.
Das ist jetzt nicht aussagekräftig.
Das ist irgendeiner, der abgefuckt ist und dann schlecht.
Also, drei sind echt ein bisschen...
So ziemlich...
Okay, es war Azubi.
Ziemlich alles von Urhalter, Hardware bis zur Räumlichkeit ist alles dabei.
Ich hab meine Ausbildung dort abgebrochen und dann...
Oh Mann.
Ja, aber das ist nicht so wirklich aussagekräftig.
Äh.
Wait a minute.
Ich wollte mir eigentlich die L-Anzeige angucken.
Okay.
Wir machen jetzt Dark Reader wieder an.
Okay, die Software wirkt schon ein bisschen...
Fragwürdig, so.
Aber es sagt nichts über den Laden.
Also, der Laden kann tatsächlich nicht schlecht sein.
Wir hatten das gepostet.
Vorhin war eine Frage.
Ähm...
Wir hatten das vorhin gepostet.
TDA.
Du musst...
Okay.
Das war das Falsche, was ich hatte.
Nee, das sind die schon.
Wir hatten das gepostet eben vorhin.
Weil, mich würde jetzt halt interessieren, derjenige, der das gepostet hat,
arbeitest du da oder wolltest du dich da bewerben?
Weil, da könntest du uns ja mal sagen, ob das...
Dass es vielleicht gar nicht so schlimm ist, wie es so aussieht.
Kennst du einen guten Cloud-Provider?
Ja, Alter, HeadSign, wo in Norwegen ist.
HeadSign ist nur in Finnland.
Norwegen weiß ich nicht.
So, Alter, lass uns mal die Stellenanzeige angucken.
Da geht es ja eigentlich drum.
Das zeichnet sie aus.
Du verfügst wieder einabgeschlossen...
Okay, die übliche Sache.
Aber man kann es ja nicht markieren.
Du bist fit am Telefon und kannst sowohl interne Anwender als auch externe Kunden beraten und betreuen.
Oh, MonkaS, da geht es schon los, Alter.
Welche Zeiterfassung läuft bei euch?
Ähm...
Äh...
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, was da im Hintergrund läuft.
Nichts, worüber...
Zumindest...
Zumindest nichts, worum ich mich kümmern muss.
Also, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Du bist kreativ in Entwicklung, Realisierung, neuartige IT-Software-Lösungen.
Ja, vielleicht welche, die auf dem Handy gescheit skalieren.
Erfordernde deutsche und gute Englischkenntnisse runden dein Profil ab.
Zuständige Hauptaufgaben, irre berufliche Zukunft.
Freue dich auf ein interessantes...
Moment, das ist alles?
Was ist das für eine Stellenanzeige, Mann?
Da ist ja nichts.
Da steht weder, was die eigentlich genau entwickeln,
äh, welche Technologien verwendet werden,
was...
Hä?
Okay, das macht keinen Sinn.
Kann man links posten?
Klar, immer her damit.
Mal kurz gucken, ob ich nicht irgendwas übersehen hab.
Naja, anscheinend nicht.
Naja, schick, ja.
Wir haben Zeit.
Wie schaut's damit aus?
Kann man gleich gucken.
Modulat.
Also, das fällt bei mir durch.
Sowohl nach kurzem Googeln, als auch die Webseite, als auch die Stellenanzeige.
Das ist wirklich echt fragwürdig.
Was hältst du davon, was bewerbungsmanagement.net...
Was ist das für eine...
Wie viele von diesen Seiten gibt es da eigentlich?
Also, falls derjenige tatsächlich dort arbeitet...
Und sich dann...
Also, ich weiß ja nicht mehr, wer es gewesen ist.
Falls derjenige dort wirklich arbeitet...
Also...
Unabhängig von der Webseite oder sowas, ist egal.
Also, dass sich da seit 2021 keiner drauf beworben hat, finde ich verständlich.
Da steht nichts drin.
Also, es steht weder drinne, was mich jetzt persönlich ansprechen würde, dass ich da hingehe,
noch irgendwas von Substanz, was denn eigentlich gesucht ist.
Anwendungsentwickler, Frontend, Backend, irgendwelche Automatisierungssachen,
welche Technologie als Basis, was wird eingesetzt...
Das ist komplett nichts.
Nichtssagend.
Ausbeutung pur, sagst du, okay.
Ja gut, das sagt der Chat.
Ich kann das natürlich nicht beurteilen.
Keine Benefits.
Letzter Versuch für die Rezension, was?
Okay, na...
TDAHR, was?
Grevenbräuch, wo ist das überhaupt?
Google-Rezession soll ich gucken, okay.
Äh...
Google?
Hä, warum ist es jetzt so vor allem auf Englisch?
Alter, Google ist schon...
Alter, wie schaffen die es bei Google eigentlich, so eine Simplizierung zu machen?
Eine simple Sache, wie einen Moorknopf zu verkacken.
So schwer kann es doch nicht sein.
Knopf draufdrücken, dann klappt mehr aus.
Yonderboy, den brauchen wir jetzt, ja.
Genau.
Der kennt sich aus.
Da war er doch...
War der nicht bei...
Bei...
AWS?
Wer ist da...
Abkontiv schlecht.
Gute Wandermöglichkeiten.
Ja, also das liest sich wirklich nicht nach einem Arbeitgeber, wo man hin will.
Hast du deine Stellenanzeige schon abgecheckt?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, welche da deine gewesen ist, aber ich hab hier...
Einige...
Einige offen.
Welche war deine?
Heute hab ich schon wieder eine andere Postleitzahl.
Amazonis, auch am G-Bain.
Muss mal ein bisschen was zumachen hier.
Zu viel.
Ähm...
Hand...
Hand hab ich nicht.
Seh ich...
Seh ich hier nicht.
Welche das...
Welche davon deine ist?
Ich hab...
Ich hab, glaub ich, alle aufgemacht, die Leute.
Ja.
Naja.
Jetzt auch Historie nix mehr.
Okay, was haben wir denn als nächstes Schönes?
Endor AG.
Spitzenleistung seit über 20 Jahren.
Ähm...
Und wo steht, was es da gibt?
Moment.
Fanatec?
Sind das nicht die mit dem...
Mit dem Headshot-Controller?
Doch, das sind die!
Shit!
Wer in Computerspielen die Nase vorn haben will, braucht eine...
Top-Ausstattung.
Und da ist der Fanatec Headshot-Controller genau das Richtige.
Das Set besteht aus einer ultrapräzisen Gamer-Maus und einem Highspeed-Pad.
Zusammen ein unschlagbares Team.
Die Maus ist super ergonomisch und lässt sich an jede Handform anpassen.
Das sorgt auch in langen Gamer-Sessions für ermüdungsfreies Spielen.
Sechs Maus-Buttons und ein Fünf-Wege-Steuerrad sorgen dafür,
dass Sie Ihre Spielfigur auch in heißen Gefechten im Griff haben.
Die Plasma-Glide-Maus-Füße sorgen zusammen mit...
...dem Highspeed-Pad für minimale Haft- und Gleitreibung für schnelles, präzises Zielen im Spiel.
Das leichte Kabel kommt Ihnen dabei garantiert nicht in die Quere.
Dafür sorgt die clevere Kabelführung.
Das sieht aus wie so eine Diebstahl-Sicherung im Baumarkt.
Fetzige Leuchteffekte mit unterschiedlichen Farben, Helligkeit und Pulsfrequenz machen das Spiel noch rasanter.
Profigamer sind begeistert von den Programmiermöglichkeiten für Maus und Tastatur.
Selbst während des Spiels.
Auch Makros lassen sich problemlos einsetzen.
Damit sind sie bei Flugsimulationen, Rennspielen und anderen Games der King.
Der Fnatic Headshot Controller ist das ultimative Set für Gamer.
Und wetten, dass er auch als Geschenk gut ankommt?
Probieren Sie es aus.
Okay, die gibt es anscheinend wirklich noch.
Und die machen eventuell heute anderes und besseres Zeug als damals.
Was?
Ähm...
Die Stellenanzeigen jetzt überhaupt.
Aktuelle Jobs.
Heu, so viel?
IT-Administrator.
Guck mal, sogar eine Physieausbildung 2025.
Ein Last-Mile-Expert.
Was meinen die denn damit?
Internet-Provider-Anschluss-Kram?
Netzwerk-Anschluss-Kram?
Was ist ein Last-Mile-Expert?
Okay, IT-Systemadministrator.
Nein, sorry, nur IT-Administrator.
The Brainful.
FACTORY.
Fifehead, quasi.
Fifehead by Design.
So, ihre Aufgaben.
Administration und Implementierung von interner IT-Infrastruktur.
Ja, das klingt passend.
Überwachung und Weiterentwicklung bestehender Systeme zur Leistungssteigerung, Risikomin- und Kostenreduktion.
Bisschen businessmäßig umschrieben, aber passt halt auch dazu.
Eigenständige Analyse von Fehlerbehebung, Störung...
Ja, Lifecycle-Management für Hard- und Software.
Standardisierung, Automatisierung von IT-Prozessen, Bereitstellung, Erweiterung, Optimierung diverser...
Was?
Policies, Exchange, Teams, Aut...
Boah!
Exchange, Alter, geh mal weg.
Aber gut, sie brauchen's halt.
Das ist jetzt nicht negativ für den Laden.
Aber da hätte ich ja keinen Bock drauf.
Also alles, was zu viel Microsoft-Kram beinhaltet, ist für mich raus.
Ich such eh nix, ja, ich sag's mal.
Also hier, hallo, ne?
Und falls mein Chef zuguckt, ich such nix.
Bereitstellung, äh, Policy...
Konzeption, Implementierung und Optimierung von Cloud- oder Hybridlösungen, primär Microsoft 365 und Azure.
Immerhin, immerhin...
Microsoft 365 und nicht mehr wie die Noobs Office 365.
Also was sie schreiben.
Migration in die Cloud sowie die Begleitung von...
Spannenden Projekten gehören zum Daily Business.
Verantwortung für das Client- und Benutzermanagement.
AD, Azure AD, Entra-ID.
Ja, das ist das Gleiche.
Ich find's aber gut, dass die die Schnellanzeige up-to-date haben mit den korrekten Namen.
Das macht auf mich immer einen guten Eindruck.
Auch wenn ich keinen Bock hätte auf Microsoft.
Zusammenarbeit mit externen Dienstleistern an Systemen und...
Okay.
Kontinuierliche Analyse, Optimierung...
Exchange...
Dokumentation von Upload...
Oh ja, das machen alle besonders gerne immer.
Ich kenne...
Das liebt jeder Admin-Unentwickler und jeder mag das überhaupt.
Ja, ich find das ganz geil.
Das Ding ist halt, die sind alle nicht Wubbler-certified.
Wenn die Wubbler-certified wären, dann wüssten die, wenn man die Sachen einfach fehlerfrei macht, dann braucht man keine Dokumentation.
Weil sie funktionieren ja.
Dokumentation brauchst du ja nur, wenn das kaputt ist und du willst nachgucken, was denn da jetzt eigentlich passiert.
Wenn es einfach funktioniert, brauchst du keine Dokumentation.
Ganz einfach.
Easy.
Das zeichnet sie aus.
Erfolgreich abgeschlossenes Beruf...
Okay, übliche Sache, mindestens 5 Jahre Praxiserfahrung...
5 Jahre Praxis...
Könnte man dem zumindest nochmal ein Senior dran pappen und ein bisschen mehr Kohle bezahlen, oder?
Problemlösungskompetenz mit der Fähigkeit, Prioritäten zu setzen...
Okay, schnelle...
Sehr gute Kenntnisse im Umgang mit Windows Active Directory, Azure Android...
Exchange, SharePoint...
So wie Windows und Linux-Servern.
Das ist halt in Kombination immer so ein Ding.
Also ich kenne Windows-Leute, die jahrelang Windows gemacht haben und jetzt bei Linux hängen geblieben sind und mit Windows nichts mehr zu tun haben wollen.
Den umgedrehten Fall, Linux-Leute, die auch ein bisschen Windows machen, kenne ich nicht.
Gibt's... Gibt's nicht.
Gefühlt. Gibt's einfach nicht.
Das liegt aber auch daran, weil du siehst, wie angenehm das sein kann und dann lockst du dich auf ein Windows-System ein und musst kotzen.
Also...
Exzellente deutsche Kenntnisse.
Leute, nicht...
Man muss sich einfach nur...
Exzellente brauchen die.
Richtig.
Die sind so pfeifert, dass...
Exzellente deutsche Kenntnisse.
Wort und Schrift.
C2.
Also das ist noch nicht mal Muttersprachniveau.
Das ist quasi noch besser, oder wie?
Moment.
C2, C1...
Ich muss jetzt mal kurz gucken.
Ah, ne.
Annähernd muttersprachliche Kenntnisse.
Ah, ja.
Man soll halt...
Gut Deutsch können.
Sehr gut Englisch kennen.
Mindestens B2.
Was ist B2?
Selbstständige Sprachverwendung.
Okay, das kriege ich gerade noch so hin.
We are all sitting in one boat.
Das bieten wir.
Nutzen Sie die Chance, Teil einer einzigen...
Das sind immer so Sprüche, Mann.
Juckt das irgendjemand, der sich eine Bewerbung durchliest?
Hat das schon irgendjemand irgendwann mal überzeugt, sowas in der Bewerbung, Mann?
Spannende internationale Projekte im Hochmarkt.
Motiviert ein sehr kollegiales Team.
Persönliche Entwicklungs...
Leistungsorientierte Vergütung mit attraktivem B...
Buff.
Altersvorsorge.
Ihre Sprachkenntnisse fördern Sie mit...
Okay.
Premium Bubble Account.
Sag mal, hat Bubble und Bubblefish was miteinander zu tun?
Das war früher so ein Desktop-Übersetzer.
Viel Spaß.
Entfallungsmöglichkeiten auf Flachrechnung.
Sofortiger Einstieg.
In Vollzeit über uns.
Okay, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Die Stellanzeige ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Ist jetzt aber auch nix, was mich irgendwie so in Verzückung versetzt, wo ich sage, oh ja, also...
Ich persönlich eh nicht, weil viel zu viel Windows.
Die Stellanzeige ist okay.
Nix, wo ich sagen würde, oh, Instant-Bewerbung ist raus, aber die ist schon okay.
Also, sagen wir mal, ich hab schon viel, viel, viel schlechtere gesehen.
So super, oh, ich muss da jetzt hin.
Ist es aber auch nicht.
Weiß ich, Chat, wie seht ihr das?
Ich finde, es ist so semi-gut, okay.
Hat sich bemüht.
Solide, ja, genau, das trifft's ganz okay.
Ja, das trifft's ganz gut, solide.
Solide, ganz okay, ja.
Genau, solide Stellen, nix selbstbewegendes.
Genauso sehe ich das auch.
Also, wenn man da Bock drauf hat, Leute, ja, und ihr kommt aus der Nähe von Landshut,
hieß nicht so die eine, die bei uns mal den Euro, die für uns, für Deutschland mal den Eurovisions-Contest,
gewonnen hat.
Lena irgendwas, Landshut?
Ne, wie hieß, wie hieß die?
Ach, Landrut, okay.
Ja, passt, ähnlich, ähnlich.
Kann man machen.
So.
Ja, Emre, was war denn, was war denn jetzt deine Stellenanzeige?
Dann machen wir die als nächstes.
Du wartest jetzt ja anscheinend schon eine Weile drauf.
Ich weiß nicht, welche, welche das ist.
Oder hast du die letztes Mal gepostet?
Nicht heute.
Okay.
Letztes Mal haben wir alle durch.
Ja, Budget ist immer interessant, ja.
Da drücken sie sich immer.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum sich da so viele Läden vordrücken.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich habe euch die Story ja schon erzählt, ne.
Kollege hat sich bei einem Laden beworben.
Budget 95 bis 105k.
Bewerbungs, äh, ja, Orgie durchgemacht.
Mit, ähm, Kennenlerntermin und dann online nochmal irgendein Szenario durchgespielt.
Und immer hieß das so.
Nach dem Motto, ja, passt alles gut.
Äh, Seniorstelle, Budget passt auch.
Und am Ende, als die fertig waren, wo es dann drum ging, den Vertrag ihm zu schicken,
haben die eben gesagt, oh, das Budget wurde doch nicht genehmigt.
Das ist jetzt keine Seniorstelle mehr.
Es gibt jetzt nur noch maximal 78k oder sowas.
Und dann hat er halt gesagt, yep, dann halt nicht.
Ist halt für beide Seiten scheiße.
Weil du hast dich lange dann mit dem Laden beschäftigt.
Der Laden hat sich lange mit einem potenziellen Kandidat beschäftigt.
Fragt man sich halt auch, wenn es schon so losgeht,
will man dann da wirklich arbeiten, ja?
Und ich denke mir halt so, was denken die sich denn?
Denken die ernsthaft?
Oh, jetzt hat uns der Kandidat kennengelernt, findet uns ganz toll.
Wenn das Erste, was er von uns hört, ist, wir halten uns nicht an das, was vereinbart war,
dann wird er bestimmt sagen, oh ja, jetzt komme ich sofort zu euch, oder wie?
Ja, also, da kann man, also was ich sagen will, ist, man kann selbst, wenn da Budget steht,
oder die einen was sagen, auch nicht zwangsläufig,
was drauf geben, aber ich fände es sinnvoll, wenn es dabei steht.
Weiß gar nicht, wie man die ausspricht.
Okay.
Jawohl, das gucken wir uns gleich an.
Weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht.
Das ist aber so Pizza in der Richtung, so türkische.
Ne, nicht wirklich Pizza, das ist so ein, ja so, so was in der Richtung.
Ne, so ein, ja doch, so was wie Pizza ist das, glaube ich.
Ich muss ja sagen, ich habe eine ganze Zeit lang,
Pide, Pide, wie nennt sich das dann, dieses, dieses Teigschiff da,
Pide mit Sucuk, fand ich eine ganze Zeit lang viel, viel nicer als klassische Salami-Pizza.
Mittlerweile habe ich wieder ein bisschen mehr Richtung Italienisch geschwenkt.
Ja, Mann, das ist so eine Pizza, ist das?
Hier, guck.
Genau das.
So eine Art Pizza.
So, ähm, also was haben die denn hier am Start, zeigt mal her.
Erste Mal, ne Webseite, die dir nicht die Augen rausbrennt, das finde ich schon mal gut.
Kennst du die nur gerollt?
Oh, wisst ihr, wo ich jetzt richtig Bock drauf hätte, wo wir gerade bei gerollt sind?
Auf Calzone-Pizza hätte ich jetzt richtig Bock drauf.
Was ist da klassischerweise immer drin?
Salami, Schinken, Pilze?
So richtig knusprig außen drumherum?
So eine Calzone-Pizza, boah, da hätte ich richtig Bock drauf jetzt.
Da würde ich, da würde ich jetzt, egal, ob ich schon was gefuttert habe oder nicht,
würde ich jetzt noch eine Runde Pepo-Fett mir reinhauen.
Äh, ja, ja, ich habe schon was gegessen.
Tatsächlich was Gesundes.
So, so Müsli mit Obstschnipsel drin.
Aber Calzone-Pizza hätte ich mega Bock drauf jetzt, ey.
Okay, deine Karriere bei Laocon?
Ich bin immer noch über die Frage, wie man das ausspricht.
Security.
Hacke und wachse gemeinsam mit uns im Team.
Auf geht's.
Endlich muss das passende, die passende Stimmung für die Stellenanzeige hier am Start haben.
Also.
Auf deinem Gebiet, wer hat einfach einen Arbeitgeber, der sich nach dir richtet.
100% cooles Team, 20% Weiterbildungszeit, 100% Homeoffice.
Das ist doch schon mal eine Ansage, oder?
Wahrscheinlich ist das ein kleines Startup, die gar kein Büro gemietet haben.
Deswegen 100% Homeoffice.
Aber, ey, soll mir recht sein.
Okay.
Offene Stellen.
Senior Penetration Tester.
Junior Penetration Tester.
Pen-Test-Trainee.
Oh, fuck.
Telefonnummer liegt.
Guck mal, die machen auch Kubernetes.
Kubernetes.
Wir sind ein Team von erfahrenen Hackern,
deren Arbeit es beginnt, wo...
Das ist nicht meine Welt.
Metasploit kenne ich.
Die anderen zwei kenne ich erst gar nicht.
Ach, soll ich euch mal was Witziges von der Arbeit erzählen?
Ich habe letztens unsere Penetration-Tester gepenetration-testet.
Die haben...
Es werden bei uns auf der Arbeit regelmäßig Phishing-Mails verschickt,
von irgendwelchen Penetration-Testern,
die dann halt gucken, wie viele Leute klicken da drauf und sonst was.
Und ich habe mir die URL mal rauskopiert.
Die in dieser Phishing-Mail drinnen war.
Und mal ausprobiert, was da so läuft drauf.
Und...
Sie hatten zumindest einen offenen SSH-Port,
allerdings keine Passwort-Authentifizierung an.
Aber sie hatten SMTP offen.
Und ich habe denen jetzt eine E-Mail geschickt per Telnet.
Per SMTP.
Mal gucken, ob die ankommt.
Und ich habe die Seite...
Ein paar Mal aufgerufen.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob in der nächsten Penetration-Auswertung
irgendwie drinnen steht,
der Link wurde irgendwie 600 Mal aufgerufen.
Dann frage ich mich so, okay, haben die richtig gefiltert?
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Ja, SSH-Login...
Aber das war bei Hetzner gehostet.
Es war bei Hetzner gehostet.
Wenn man die jetzt hätte ärgern wollen,
hätte man die an Hetzner schicken können.
Ja, es ist...
Es war eine URL mit einer ID pro Jungs.
Und mit einem User hintendran.
Also im Endeffekt, ich habe die mit der ID Kekkel aufgerufen.
Die wird es ja nicht geben.
Aber ich bin mal gespannt, was da bei der Auswertung rauskommt.
Okay, offene Stellen...
Gut, macht jetzt keinen Sinn.
Ja, ohne ID...
Habe ich auch getestet.
Gab es eine ganz normale...
HTTP-Response.
Hab da nur einen Curl drauf gemacht.
Ja gut, das muss ich mir jetzt nicht weiter angucken.
Das ist nicht wirklich da, wo meine Expertise jetzt sonderlich groß ist.
Wo ich da viel dazu sagen könnte.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich finde die Aufmachung der Seite
und wie sich das hier anhört,
tatsächlich relativ ansprechend.
Es ist so ein bisschen Start-Up mäßig hier auf jeden Fall alles, oder?
Ja.
Ich glaube,
wenn man auch sowas Bock hat
und die passenden Skills hat,
ist das bestimmt nice.
Guck mal, die schreiben sogar die Kohle
rein hier.
Ja gut, das ist halt...
Das ist ja fast eine Spanne von 100%.
Das ist das Doppelte.
Das ist halt schon...
Ja, okay.
Aber immerhin.
Ich finde es gut, wenn sowas drin steht.
Ja, wir geben zwischen wenig und viel Geld.
Aber ist okay.
Finde ich nicht schlecht.
Auch, dass sie direkt sagen,
Alter, Homeoffice, wir haben gar kein Büro in dem Sinn.
Ja, nicht verkehrt.
In dem Bereich,
als Senior-Pentester ist das auf jeden Fall nicht
die Welt.
Das hätte ich...
Ey, das hätte ich mal ausprobieren müssen.
Als ID irgendwie
Semi-Colon-Drop-Table.
Aber da war keine Datenbank dahinter.
Gehe ich ganz stark von aus.
Das war einfach nur irgendein lackischer Nginx.
Wo dann im Endeffekt
in den Logs geguckt wird,
wer hat die Seite aufgerufen.
Ja, das ist nur ein bisschen wenig.
Da kommst du ja gar nicht über die Runden.
So, also weiter.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Entwickle moderne Apps.
Also Chat, wenn ihr noch was habt,
wir haben Zeit, nur her damit.
Und falls ich es übersehe,
müsst ihr mich nochmal
addwubblos dabei schreiben.
Wen haben wir denn hier als nächstes?
Apps...
Menz?
Ja, Menz heißt das.
Menz in München.
Vollzeit und Teilzeit.
Das ist doch schon mal was.
Das wird schon in Datenbank geschrieben.
Die durchsuche nicht durch Logs. Warum?
Ich würde das machen.
Du rechnest da im Endeffekt mit, keine Ahnung,
vielleicht 300-400 Aufrufen
bei sowas. Klar, warum nicht?
Ich würde da keine Datenbank einschreiben.
Ich würde die Logs, die Aufrufe
gucken, gut ist.
TIT AG, mit Sicherheit an ihrer Seite.
Okay.
Jetzt gucken wir uns aber erst mal Menz an.
Sie suchen einen Entwickler für moderne Apps.
Was moderne Apps sind,
ist natürlich jetzt
eine
große Bandbreite. Da stellen sich
sicherlich, wenn du fünf Leute fragst,
kriegst du fünf Antworten.
Aber die sind schon mal so modern,
dass die alle zusammen um den Macbook rumsitzen
und draufgucken und begeistert aussehen.
Wir wollen als Digita...
Moment, Moment, Moment. Was?
Passwort Bingo geht los.
Wir wollen als Digital Pathfinders...
Leute, jetzt...
Junior.
Ein Senior C-Sharp Softwareentwickler.
Interessant.
Borussia.de
Ob wir das alles schaffen? Kann schon sein.
Also,
als digitale Pathfinders
die Mobilität
von morgen mitgestalten und mit unseren
Produkten bei der Verkehrswende unterstützen,
um eine nachhaltigere Zukunft
ehrenwerte Ziele
zu erreichen.
Deswegen sehen die auch so...
Das geht natürlich nur auf dem Mac.
Das sollte ja allen klar sein.
Dazu haben wir ein...
Wir bieten richtungsweise auf,
der Planer optimieren Verkehrs...
Suchen wir dich für die Entwicklung
von modernen Apps.
Wie sieht dein...
Wie sieht dein Alltag aus?
Du begeisterst dich für Mobilität
und daraus...
Du hast ein starkes Interesse daran,
an nationalen
und internationalen Produkten zu arbeiten,
die die Mobilität von morgen
maßgeblich prägen.
Da wäre ich doch genau richtig so als alter
Bahnflamer, oder?
Ich habe ein großes Interesse an Mobilität.
Ja, fick die Bahn, Mann!
Das kann man...
Ist doch Interesse an Mobilität.
Du hast ein starkes Interesse...
Du bist bereits Neues zu den Neutechnologien
und Produktfelder oder individuelle Fähigkeiten.
Du bringst sehr gute Kenntnisse mit,
in der App-Entwicklung,
in Android, iOS oder im Cross...
Plattform...
Achso! Oder im Cross...
Das ist einfach nur...
Okay, das habe ich falsch gelesen,
aber das ist auch blöd geschrieben.
Oder im Cross-Plattform-Framework Flutter mit.
Flutter? Bin ich Experte.
Kann ich auch beweisen.
Kann ich beweisen.
Ich bin Flutter-Expert.
Ja.
Meine Flutter-App.
Viele Sachen starten.
Überhaupt.
Es wird Zeit, Leute.
Ich würde sagen...
Zeit Start-Up zu gründen, oder?
Also, wenn das jetzt mal nicht
dafür reichen sollte,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Also für die erste Flutter-App hier.
Beste App, oder?
Erste Flutter-App hier.
Ja, also ich glaube,
das geht als Bewerbung
direkt raus.
Du hast Kenntnisse in aktuellen
Mobile-Betriebssystemen,
Stores und Ökosystemen.
Du kennst dich in moderner Software-Entwicklung,
Software-Architektur und qualifizierst dich immer aus.
Du hast richtig Lust auf das Thema.
Du bist motiviert, neugierig auf neue IT-Systeme, Technik in der IT-Welt.
Du arbeitest selbstständig, zuverlässig,
exakt, hast Freude an Sachen.
Mit anderen Menschen, okay.
Da falle ich schon mal raus.
Ich habe keinen Bock an eine Zusammenarbeit mit anderen Menschen.
Einfach Clip einchecken und die lassen sich...
Genau, mit dieser krassen Flutter-App,
bewerben die sich bei mir.
Ja, wollte ich, aber das machen wir heute.
Du bringst Spaß und Bereitschaft mit,
als Systemvergleicher.
Du hast eine Zertifizierung
zum AWS Practitioner
oder, ich sage absichtlich AWS,
weil ich AW,
weil W legit
die dümmste Aussprache
eines Buchstabens ever ist.
Du bist AWS Practitioner
oder vergleichbares Cloud-Wissen.
Weiterführen, okay.
Du hast Linux, Windows,
Windows und seine Standard-Tools.
Flexible
Gleitzeiten, zentrale
Anbindungen, Bio-Kaffee aus
der regionalen Rösterei.
Der Obstkorb ist auch am Start.
Teamübergreifende Events
wie Wandern, Skifahren. Alter, lasst
mir in meiner Freizeit doch die Ruhe, aber cool
für diejenigen, die da Bock drauf haben.
Okay Leute, ich sage euch mal ernst ehrlich, was ich davon halte.
Ich glaube, das ist
eine...
ein cooler Job für Leute,
die nicht so sind wie ich.
Das ist,
das klingt super Startup-mäßig
und
ja, man muss
sich sehr begeistern können
für dieses Themengebiet.
Man darf nicht die Erwartung
haben, viel Kohle zu verdienen,
ist mein Eindruck davon.
Zumindest nicht direkt.
Ja, und man muss halt auf
hippe, junge Leute
muss man mögen.
Ich glaube, wenn
einen das anspricht, dann ist
das echt nicht verkehrt.
Ich glaube, die Stellenanzeige ist
insofern
gut, als dass sie
genau das transportiert, was sie
transportieren soll.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht schlecht,
wenn man da Bock drauf hat.
Ich nicht.
Wenn das hier jemand anspricht,
ist das glaube ich nicht
verkehrt.
So, next.
Ja, aber Startup bekommst du immer wenig
Kohle.
Es sei denn, du bekommst Anteile, bleibst
lange genug dabei und der Kram wird dann
irgendwann mal super viel wert oder
verkauft.
Gelder sehen stabil aus, da habe ich mich
vielleicht geirrt, aber so wirkt das.
Sie haben ja geschrieben, das ist irgendwie
so ein Fünf-Mann-Unternehmen aus
ehemaligen Studienkollegen.
So, wen haben wir denn als nächstes?
Wie gesagt, ich finde es nicht schlecht,
aber halt überhaupt nichts für mich.
Plus, Line, On...
Wie viele Seiten gibt es eigentlich?
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Das ist jetzt schon irgendwie die achte
Seite heute.
Früher hat man noch bei meine Stadt
geguckt und sowas.
Ja, okay, ich gebe zu, das war 2005,
2004.
Gibt es das überhaupt noch?
Meine Stadt?
Das sieht immer noch genauso hässlich
aus wie damals.
Okay, also was haben wir denn hier?
Plus, Line...
Der Name sagt mir irgendwas.
Sie kommen aus Frankfurt.
Das kenne ich. Das sagt mir was.
Plus, Line?
Kommt mir bekannt vor.
Okay, der Name kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Gut, ich meine Frankfurt
und Umgebung, so ein paar Sachen hast du halt einfach schon gehört.
Aha.
Die Boni für Recruiter, die sind ziemlich
nice.
Ich habe mal was irgendwo aufgeschnappt,
dass irgendeiner drei Monatsgehälter bekommt.
Wobei das sicherlich auch schon
outdated ist. Heute bist du
okay, wenn du komplett
vermittelst, also dass du quasi nicht
dem Typ nur den Job vermittelst,
sondern die Leute vermittelst, dann
kriegst du ja monatlich dafür was.
Okay, also
sucht ab sofort in Frankfurt
Hybrid oder Remote.
Okay.
Sie suchen einen Junior System Engineer
Linux, also quasi mich
in jung.
Also, ich würde das machen,
wenn ich dann auch wieder im richtigen Alter wäre.
Also, wenn die mich jetzt resetten können
auf sagen wir mal so 25,
dann würde ich das machen.
Es gibt doch Seniorstellen auch, weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß nur das, was der Chat mir
gepostet hat. Ja, das ist
exakt meine
Jobbezeichnung.
Also, ich würde den Job machen, wenn die mich resetten
können auf 25. Also,
nicht das Jahr resetten.
Ich will nicht, dass es wieder irgendwie
oder so ist.
Ich will 2024 haben
und 25 wieder sein. Das ist okay.
Dann würde ich den Job machen.
Egal, was die mir bezahlen. 15,
also quasi 15 Jahre resetten
können die mir dann, müssen die mir gar nichts.
Das mach ich umsonst. Okay, also
gesucht ab sofort in Frankfurt
Hybrid und Remote. Wir bieten
...
eine steile Lernkurve
dank
breitem Spektrum an angesetzten
Menschen. Sollte man das wirklich
reinschreiben
direkt in den ersten Satz?
Steile Lernkurve schreckt doch erstmal ab.
Ja, es ist immer ein neuer
Jobeinstieg, ist eine steile Lernkurve.
Und wenn die jetzt noch explizit sagen
steile Lernkurve, das klingt
dann eher so, okay, sie schmeißen
dir am ersten Tag 100 Begriffe
an den Kopf und du weißt überhaupt nicht, was die von dir wollen.
Wie kommst du zu dieser Einstellung? Zu welcher?
Du meinst, dass ich
2024 wieder 25
sein will?
Ja, weil 25 sein nicer ist, als fast
40 sein.
Ganz einfach.
Was ich nicht will, ist, dass wieder 2010 ist.
Ich hab ja keinen Bock nochmal
die gleichen 15 Jahre zu erleben.
Ich hätte gerne einfach jetzt
jetzt plus, also quasi
minus 15 Jahre vom Alter her.
So nice
mit 25 bist du dann auch einfach viel
weiß ich
viel, viel jünger
und funzt alles noch besser
als mit fast 40.
Ist jetzt nicht so als
viel agiler, da kannst du diagonal
skalieren mit 25.
Wenn du das richtige Mindset hast.
Musst das richtige Business machen.
Ich hätte echt kein Problem
damit, wenn ich 15 Jahre jünger wäre wieder.
Wir bieten dir einen attraktiven Eindruck.
Das hatten wir schon.
Wenn du Begeisterung für Linux und Open Source
mitbringst, dich komplexe Hosting-
Plattformen, professionelle Virtualisierungs-
Techniken und aktuellste
Automatisierungssysteme wie zum Beispiel
Ansible und Puppet. Ok, Puppet ist nicht
aktuellste Automatisierungssysteme.
Puppet ist so Legacy-
Kram, den eigentlich alle gerade loswerden wollen.
Also nicht wirklich Legacy
in Form von wenig mal supported, aber du findest
so gut wie keine Leute mehr dafür.
Du aber auch Projekte im Bereich
Kubernetes
IT-Secure und Managed Cloud spannend findest.
Bist du... Klingt gut?
Klingt gut?
Find ich...
Tatsächlich eine
gelungen, bis auf die steile Lernkurve
finde ich eine gute Introduction.
Es ist nicht
Selbstbeweihräucherung von so einem halben Roman
Selbstbeweihräucherung. Es ist kurz und
knackig und die passenden Buzzwords
drinnen, na außer Puppet vielleicht jetzt,
was die Leute, die
sowas mögen, anspricht.
Für Intro finde ich schon mal nicht schlecht.
Ach ja, derjenige,
der das gepostet hat, arbeitest
du da oder willst du dich da bewerben?
Also...
BashDruid
Der Name passt schon mal.
Also wenn es um Linux-Shells und so geht.
Was ersetzt Puppet?
Dachte es wird noch für Windows-Provisioning.
Also als ich Puppet und Windows-Provisioning
in Kombination gesehen habe,
war das grausam schlecht.
Ganz einfach, Windows professionierst du nicht.
Du verwendest einfach kein Windows.
Was wird dir zutrauen? Du baust komplexe
Hosting-Plattformen auf und sorgst für
deren reibungslosen Betrieb?
Verantworte das Konfigurationsmanagement
und die Systemverwaltung für deine Projekte.
Steigere die Performance durch
Beobachtung und Optimierung.
Bau als Teil des Teams komplexe
Cloud-Lösungen auf
und packe weiter Virtualisierung
mit an.
Entwickle Lösungen für Probleme noch bevor diese entstehen.
Proaktiv sozusagen.
AI-based Troubleshooting.
Dokumentiere dein...
Die sind auch nicht Wubbler-certified.
Die ganzen Kack-Noobs, alter.
Dokumentation, Mensch.
Der Kram muss einfach funktionieren.
Toll, wenn du das hier mitbringst.
Abgeschlossenes IT-Ausbildung.
Spaß an euren Herausforderungen.
Echtes Interesse an Linux und Open Source.
Sicherer Umgang mit der Kommandozeile
und dem Editor.
Gut, dass das drinnen steht.
Interesse an zusätzliche Verdienstmöglichkeiten
im Rahmen einer Rufbereitung.
Wichtig sind sehr gute Deutschkenntnisse,
Wort und Schrift.
Aber wichtiger als erlernte Skills
sind uns dein Mindset.
Die High-Performer sind am Start.
Dein Mindset und der Wille etwas Neues.
Das finde ich aber gut,
dass das da steht.
Das finde ich auch oftmals wichtiger
als das, dass du eine Sache gut kannst.
Viel wichtiger ist,
dass die Leute gut passen
zu dem jeweiligen Unternehmen.
Vor allem zu dem jeweiligen Team.
Und, dass es Leute sind,
die sich halt einfach
auf den Weg bringen.
Einarbeiten und sich das angucken.
Das dauert ein bisschen,
aber dann hast du wenigstens jemand,
der Ahnung hat von dem,
wie es das Unternehmen braucht.
Weil ganz im Ernst,
nur weil du Ansible kannst,
weil du Terraform kannst,
weil du mit irgendwelchen Cloud-Sachen
und Kubernetes schon mal was gemacht hast,
heißt das noch lange nicht,
dass du weißt, wie das jeweilige Unternehmen
das genau benutzt und was sie damit machen.
Das ist immer nur die halbe Miete,
um das zu kennen,
dass die zweite Hälfte ist,
okay, was machen die damit?
Deswegen finde ich es tatsächlich ganz gut,
dass sie das geschrieben haben.
Nicht ganz, was ihr Karriere seid.
Also ehrlich, ich finde das nicht schlecht.
Verantwortung, Freiraum von Anfang an,
steile Lernkurve durch Komplexe.
Naja, das ist eher so.
80% ITler,
die gerne ihr Wissen teilen.
Was ist denn ein 80% ITler?
Teilzeit?
Nee.
Was ist ein 80% ITler?
Wollen die nicht einen 100% ITler?
Okay, den Satz verstehe ich nicht.
Chef hat ebenfalls
einen technischen Background.
Das finde ich nice,
dass das da steht.
Die wissen schon mal,
was oftmals problematisch ist.
20% Random Shit.
Leistungsgerechtes Gehalt,
Urlaubs- und Weihnachtsgeld.
Sagen sie alle.
Flexible Arbeitszeit, Arbeitsmodelle.
Gut, dass Homeoffice drinsteht.
Top Ausstand im Laptop und Diensthandy.
Ja gut, Diensthandy muss, wenn ihr wollt,
dass man Berufsbereitschaft macht.
Muss das sein.
30 Euro kostenfreies Jobticket.
Zentrales Office nahe Hauptbahnhof.
Vielleicht habe ich die da schon mal gesehen?
Mir kommt der Name übelst bekannt vor.
Jobrat, Freizeit, Fitnessstudio,
Snacks, Getränke und Kaffeebar.
Oh, gehen wir fort.
Ich finde es nicht schlecht.
Also ich muss sagen,
das ist die Stellenanzeige.
Ich sage absichtlich nicht,
dass es die beste Stellenanzeige ist heute.
Aber das ist die Stellenanzeige,
die mich persönlich von dem, was mich interessiert,
bisher am meisten anspricht.
Das andere waren halt einfach auch Sachen dabei,
die überhaupt nicht so mein Themengebiet sind.
Mit Windows oder
Verkehrskram in Berlin und sowas.
Aber das ist die Stellenanzeige,
die mich noch am ehesten anspricht heute.
Leider vermute ich mal,
bezahlen sie nicht so viel.
Weil sie schreiben nicht umsonst
Junior davor.
Haben die auch...
Okay, dein Job.
Okay, es gibt auch noch einen normalen System-Engineer
in Linux.
Windows, MonkaS, Alter.
Wollen die da was anderes?
Okay, da wollen sie tatsächlich
ein bisschen mehr haben.
Da steht auch, das finde ich cool,
da steht da tatsächlich auch ein bisschen mehr.
Linux-basierte Serverlandschaft,
ich spreche die Sprache der Kunden.
Auch wenn ich mit Kunden nicht allzu viel zu tun habe.
Qualitäts- und Verlöseprobleme
für Teile der Anwendung.
Drei Jahre Erfahrung,
sichere Umgang mit Kommandozeile,
Betriebssystem CentOS, Red Hat,
Debian, sehr gute
MySQL, MonkaS, ja gut, warum nicht.
Gängiger Open Source Software,
Apache, Nginx,
Vanish. Okay, ich bin ein Noob,
ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Gehört? Habe ich es schon mal, aber ich weiß aus dem Kopf
nicht, was es ist.
Äh, what?
Reverse Caching Proxy.
Aha, okay.
Tomcat, Wildfly,
Postfix, Dove,
ah, die machen auch E-Mails selbst.
Das ist auch mal was.
Ansible Puppet,
KVM, Red Hat,
ich hoffe nicht.
Grundlegendes Verständnis von Programmiersprachen,
PHP, Python, Java,
Java,
Shell Scripting,
also vom
Skillset her würde ich sagen, passt das heute von den
ganzen Stellenanzeigen noch am besten.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, weil die Stellenanzeige
ist auch gut und ansprechend,
dass der Chef wirklich Ahnung von Technik
hat und es nicht nur dasteht, weil irgendjemand
ist verantwortlich für die Stellenanzeige.
Oh, was hast du geschrieben? Habe ich nicht
gesehen. Äh, ups.
Alter.
Twitch.
Nee, war aber nicht.
Was ist denn? Na.
Frage, bisschen out of Context.
Wie angemessen findest du
75k pro Jahr für 4 Jahre Erfahrung
plus 2 Jahre Ausbildung?
Habe ein Bachelor und Titel ist
Plattform-Ingenieur. Ja, also das kann man.
Klingt erstmal pauschal nicht so
übel. Man kann das
jetzt allerdings nicht so global sagen,
weil das hängt immer sehr von Region
und Branche ab.
Frankfurt Finanzbranche
geht durchaus mehr,
aber insgesamt klingt das erstmal gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Es kommt halt, wie gesagt, auf Branche und Region an,
aber insgesamt würde ich sagen, ja.
Nicht verkehrt.
Hast du eine Meinung zu Management-IT-Jobs?
Sowas wie Business-Analyse-Requirements?
Ja, da habe ich eine Meinung
dazu. Lass mich in Ruhe damit.
Aber ich finde es gut, dass es Leute gibt, die das freiwillig
machen. Dann muss ich es nicht machen.
Ich könnte das auch gar nicht.
So, was haben wir als nächstes? Die hatten wir gerade schon.
Jetzt haben wir TTT-IT.
Die Leute erzählen viel
Mist, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Wenn du irgendjemanden hast,
der da schon länger dabei ist,
je nachdem, kann das durchaus sein.
Aber wichtig ist, dass du damit zufrieden bist.
Selbe Position.
Ja, ähnliche Firma als heute.
Also wichtig ist, dass du damit zufrieden bist.
Also wie gesagt, man kann es natürlich global nicht sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, welche Region,
welche Branche und sonst was.
Aber ich finde 75k nach 4 Jahren echt in Ordnung.
Damit verdienst du, glaube ich,
eine ganze Ecke mehr als der Durchschnitt.
Ich würde sagen,
wahrscheinlich schon eher so Top 20,
25% oder so.
Hätte ich jetzt
bauchgefühlmäßig gesagt.
Weil das Durchschnittsgeil ist echt nicht so hoch.
Ganz so viel
ist 75k auch wieder nicht.
Es gab doch beim Spiegel letztens
so eine Übersicht.
So, also
was haben wir jetzt? TTT-IT AG.
Mit Sicherheit
an ihrer Seite.
auf ihrer Seite werden wir eigentlich
lieber.
Da weiß ich, dass ich nicht gebetet werde.
Arbeitszeit ist Lebenszeit.
Ja.
Da ist was dran.
Freude und Spaß bei der Arbeit
ist die Basis für Erfolg im Job.
Ja, okay.
Neben den individuellen Stärken unserer Mitarbeiter
ist das Team, okay, blablabla.
Auf höchstem Niveau dabei.
Besuchen Sie uns auch auf einem YouTube.
Gucken wir mal hier.
Jetzt wird es aber professional.
Wie, das war's?
Hält sich jetzt der Enkel an?
Okay, also.
Das wird bestimmt wieder ein cringe
Selbst-Promotion-Video.
Ähm.
Die suchen überhaupt nichts.
Die suchen nur Azubis.
Wer hat denn das gepostet?
Willst du dich da bewerben als Azubi?
Oder wie?
Bill in time?
Okay, das ist selten.
Das habe ich ja, glaube ich,
noch nie gesehen, dass jemand
explizit nach der Ausbildung
nach einem Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration sucht.
Die suchen nach allem Möglichen,
aber nicht nach einem Fisi.
Okay, direkt ins PDF. Nice.
Okay.
Wir suchen ab sofort in Vollzeit
Fachinformatiker Systemintegration.
Wir sind ein Erfolg...
Okay, blablabla. Deine Aufgaben.
Office.
Warum alles so viel Microsoft-Shit
immer, Mensch?
Es gibt so viele nice Sachen.
Aber alle wollen
sich einen Microsoft-Shit machen.
Konfiguration und Administration
von Windows-Servern wird ja immer schlimmer.
Also für mich persönlich.
Wenn ihr das mögt, kann das toll sein.
Also insofern.
Aber für mich.
Ich würde da Anfälle bekommen, wenn...
Weil...
Weil Windows und...
Ich zusammen.
Das wird nix.
Okay.
Konzeption, Umsetzung, Betreuung von Virtual...
Hyper-V.
Aufbau und Betreuung von Kundennetzen.
Eigenverantwortung.
Kundensupport.
Kundenbetreuung und Softwareinstallation.
Sehr gute Kenntnisse in der
Administration von Windows-Servern.
Gute Kenntnisse im Bereich Netzwerk,
Technik, Firewalls, Routing,
VPN und WLAN.
Sehr gute
Hardware-Kenntnisse, fundierte Kenntnisse
im Bereich Virtualisierung,
Telefonanlagen
oder sowas.
Ist jetzt ein bisschen...
Sehr allgemein.
Aber...
Ich lese daraus raus.
Sie suchen jemanden, der sich mit Windows
auskennt und ein bisschen Netzwerk-Kram machen kann.
Für mich ist es nix.
Immerhin, und das muss man ihnen
zugutehalten, schön kurz und
knackig.
Weiß man Bescheid?
Bisschen mehr Details, was denn genau, wie, wo
eingesetzt wird, vielleicht nicht verkehrt,
aber geht, klar, ist
nur noch 15 Stellen Anzeige.
Aber vielleicht wird's ja besser,
wenn wir uns das Video dazu angucken.
Warte mal kurz, du bist auch IT-Lern...
Alter!
Warum schmeißt der mir direkt was ins Gesicht?
Was ist da los?
Hey, warte mal kurz.
Du bist auch IT-Lern, wartest ständig auf Updates?
Dann mach doch einen Arsch.
Hey, warte mal kurz.
Hey, im Headshot!
Der braucht den Fanatic-Headshot-Controller.
Du bist auch IT-Lern, wartest ständig auf Updates?
Dann mach doch einen Arbeitgeber-Update
und komm zu uns ins Team.
Alter, was macht der mit seinen Fingern?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Wenn du eine neue Herausforderung
in deinem Leben haben willst,
dann bist du bei uns genau richtig,
weil bei uns ist jeden Tag
eine neue Herausforderung,
eine neue technische Innovation zu erlernen.
Jeden Tag eine neue technische Innovation?
Alter, die haben aber mal einen ziemlich
äußerst agil, diagonal skalierenden Workflow.
Mein Name ist Erik,
arbeite bei der TGT IT AG in Trier
und bin Senior Systems Engineer hier.
Meine Schwerpunkte sind
neben der Windows-Welt Exchange und Citrix.
Exchange und Citrix?
Bitte immer schlimmer!
Umgebungen auf neueren Stand zu migrieren.
Wenn du bei uns anfangen willst,
wir freuen uns auf dich.
Wir erwarten dich auf jeden Fall.
Spannende Herausforderungen
und ein super, super Arbeitsklima.
Der Haupt-Benefit...
Wisst ihr, was die beste Antwort ist,
die ihr geben könnt auf die Frage,
warum wollen sie denn ausgerechnet bei uns arbeiten?
Musst du sagen,
weil ich nicht unter der Brücke schlafen will,
ich brauch Geld.
Finde ich neben der Stimmung
diese Veranstaltung, die wir machen,
dass die Leute Lust darauf haben.
Also auch viel neben dem normalen Arbeiten
versuchen wir auch miteinander klarzukommen,
was letztendlich natürlich auch
Team-Events, jawoll!
funktionieren,
die Schnittstellen deutlich verbessern.
Ich bin Timo.
Nein, das sollt ihr natürlich nicht wirklich sagen!
TGT IT AG als Junior System Engineer
im Bereich Infrastruktur.
Das wäre aber ehrlich!
Ich bin Marie Prenk, arbeite bei der TGT IT AG
als Systems Engineer.
Ich kümmere mich eher um die...
Diese hippe Musik im Hintergrund!
Ansonsten benutze ich auch mal
einen Schraubenzieher,
wenn wir die Serverschränke dazu...
Da hätte ich auch mal wieder Bock drauf,
Leute, ich sag's euch ehrlich.
Ich hätte echt wieder Bock mal
ins Rechenzentrum zu gehen
und da ein bisschen Zeug einzubauen.
Ich habe das früher täglich gemacht
und jetzt jahrelang gar nicht mehr.
Ich würde das gerne mal wieder machen.
Jetzt nicht hauptberuflich oder so,
aber ich würde gerne mal wieder...
...zusammenbauen.
Ach, eine neue Mitarbeiterin
sollte Spaß an der Arbeit haben,
Spaß am Umgang mit Menschen
und natürlich über gute Fachkenntnisse
im IT-Bereich.
Also ganz ehrlich, die wenigsten ITler haben Bock
und Spaß am Umgang mit Menschen.
Deswegen machen wir das ja auch.
Wir kennen uns alle inzwischen.
Weil wir zum größten Teil sonnenscheue
Kellerkinder sind, die keinen Bock auf andere Leute haben.
Sehr gut.
Auch neue werden gut eingearbeitet.
Wir unterstützen uns.
Hey, wenn du das, was du bisher gesehen hast,
wenn dir das gefällt,
wenn du in einer coolen Firma arbeiten willst,
mit tollen Leuten, mit einem tollen Team...
Also, zwei Sachen.
Es hat mich jetzt
nicht irgendwie super überzeugt,
dass ich da hin will, aber
ich habe schon deutlich schlimmere
Self-Promotion-Videos gesehen
als das.
Also, geht schon in Ordnung.
Ja, das Video könnte echt schlimmer sein.
Ja, denke ich auch.
Geht schon, geht schon.
Aber zu viel Windows.
Aber wenn ihr da Bock habt
drauf, Leute,
TTT IT in...
Wo sind denn die überhaupt?
Ähm... Trio.
Okay.
Next. Was haben wir denn jetzt hier?
Okay, die mag ich schon mal.
Die haben eine Webseite,
die nicht flashbangt,
selbst ohne Darkreader.
Wo ist
Murnau?
Am Staffelsee. Okay.
Am Staffelsee, neben dem Riegsee.
Ja.
Wo ist das?
Das Blaue Land.
Ich habe immer noch keine Ahnung, wo das ist.
Bayern bestimmt, ne?
Badenkirchen. Okay, da kommen wir schon eher...
Okay, Bayern. Ganz im Süden.
Was würdest du
statt Microsoft 365
einer großen Firma einsetzen?
Nix Microsoft 365, aber ich will mich nicht
drum kümmern müssen.
School and Office ist nach wie vor, dass die Leute
seit 20 Jahren kennen.
Ich persönlich mache
soweit es geht einen großen Bogen um
alles, was ich in Office machen muss.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist
Office wahrscheinlich immer noch das Beste, was du verwenden kannst.
Irgendwer muss sich
drum kümmern. Ja, solange das du nicht ich bist, ist das okay.
Machst du ASCII-Docs?
Nee.
Ich mache meistens, wenn ich Sachen
für mich mache, reines TXT,
was man im Zweifelsfall als Markdown formatiert,
irgendwie auch ein bisschen schöner
rendern kann.
Und ansonsten,
Presentation-Stells mache ich mittlerweile
tatsächlich auch in Powerpoint.
Ich habe es lange Zeit auch in
Markdown gemacht, dann als PDF
exportiert. Aber gucken wir mal,
was Codewerk
haben möchte.
Oh, guck mal! Ein Senior
C-Lattenzaun
Softwareentwickler.
Codewerk steht für Technikbegeisterung,
Innovation und Zuverlässigkeit
mit flachen Hierarchien.
Okay.
GPT, generiere mir eine
Einleitung für meine
Stellenanzeige. Ob in Zügen
oder Industrieanlagen,
also dann für Windows 3.11 sozusagen.
Wir bringen die Systeme von morgen
dazu, miteinander zu reden. Dabei brauchen wir
deine Hilfe. Wir suchen
clevere Köpfe für die Entwicklung von
industriellen Software-Systemen für
morgen. Also, deine Aufgaben.
Du bringst dein Wissen
in unsere... Okay, das ist bla bla.
Du verantwortest, gestaltest
den gesamten Entwicklungsprozess
angefangen von den ersten
Klärungen, der Anfang über Konzeption, Design,
Implementierung bis zur Übergabe an den Kunden.
Ja gut, das ist...
Sagen wir mal so. Du bist nicht einfach nur
Entwickler, du bist Senior-Entwickler.
Bei manch anderen wärst du vielleicht auch Architekt,
wenn man sowas hier dann liest, aber...
Ja...
Du entwickelst und
programmierst .NET, C-Sharp,
Anwendungen einschließlich GUI und
Schnittstellen zu Fremdsystemen.
Ob die noch .NET Framework unter Windows
Only verwenden?
Es liest sich ein bisschen so.
Weil, ansonsten...
Ja gut, ich meine, du kannst
auch .NET Core mit WPF und Windows Forms
machen, das geht genauso.
Aber die haben bestimmt noch jede Menge Legacy
Anwendungen.
.NET Framework 481,
Windows Forms,
alles WPF Zeug.
Ich meine, alle waren immer noch angenehmer als Maui.
Maui ist auch so ein richtig krasser
Rohrkrepierer. Ich warte jeden Tag
auf den Blogpost, dass Microsoft sagt,
Maui wird...
Maui wird eingestellt.
Wenn es .NET GUI sein soll, dann
Avalonia.
Vielleicht doch besser gar kein GUI in .NET.
Datenmodellierung,
Entwicklung von Datenbanken und
NoSQL-Systemen. Du integrierst
Anwendungen in Frameworks im Umfeld
von Industrie 4.0
IoT. Moment!
IoT ist jetzt
neuerdings Industrie 4.0?
Wer hat sich das denn ausgedacht?
Geeignete Methoden, zum Beispiel aus
der agilen Softwareentwicklung, nutzt du
bei deiner täglichen Arbeit.
Das ist vollkommen egal, ob ich Methoden aus der
agilen Softwareentwicklung nutze.
Wenn nur ich das mache, hat das keinen Sinn.
Entweder macht es mein Team oder das Projekt
oder es macht keinen Sinn.
Ich kann nicht sagen, ich arbeite
agil alleine.
Und der Rest der Leute, die an der Anwendung
arbeiten, nicht.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Ah, lass kurz Daily machen.
Ah, okay.
Ich hab nix für heute.
Fertig. Bin ja nur allein.
Macht irgendwie keinen Sinn.
Ich weiß, was sie meinen.
Dass du sowas vielleicht schon mal gemacht hast.
Irgendjemand hat halt
agile Softwareentwicklung jetzt
zum Mainstream-Standard
erklärt, dass jeder agil Software
entwickeln muss.
Und alle denken halt, es ist cool,
wenn man agile Softwareentwicklung
einschreibt.
Die wenigsten Projekte sind wirklich agil.
Die schreiben, dass sie agil sind,
weil es sich auf Manager-Ebene cool anhört
und sich nice buzzword bingo mäßig
verkaufen lässt.
Aber machen dann
äußerst unagile Dinger.
Wie zum Beispiel, dass der Projektleiter
auch das Scrum Master sein soll und sowas.
Das ergibt einfach gar keinen Sinn.
In deinen Projekten prüfst du die Anwendbarkeit
neuer Technologien und Innovationen.
Okay. Ja.
Macht Sinn.
Also, man muss prinzipiell
immer
die neuesten Frameworks und Technologien
einsetzen und in keinem Projekt zweimal das gleiche.
Ne, aber das passt schon.
Also, man könnte den Satz ja auch so
interpretieren, man soll sich
ein bisschen für neue Entwicklungen und Technik
interessieren und das ist
Grundvoraussetzung dafür. Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Wir bauen auf dein Wissen und Know-How
und diese Basis bringst du auf jeden Fall mit.
Okay. Du hast einen abgeschlossenen Studium
in Informatik, Media und vergleichbare Ausbildung.
Du bringst mehrjährige Erfahrung
in der Softwareentwicklung mit.
UML!
No! No!
God, please, no! No!
No!
Macht das wirklich irgendjemand?
Die einzigen UML-Diagramme, die ich je gesehen habe,
sag mal, im Business Enterprise Umfeld,
waren irgendwelche von,
ja, wahrscheinlich damals noch Eclipse
automatisch generierten Dinger.
Ansonsten habe ich das
nie wirklich großartig
in Verwendung gesehen. Vielleicht liege ich da falsch.
Ich meine, das ist bekannt, ja, und das wird nicht umsonst
sogar in der Ausbildung teilweise gemacht.
Aber ich habe es in freier Wildbahn,
ich persönlich jetzt, noch nie
im großen Stil gesehen.
Ihr macht auch viel? Ja, das ist mal so unterschiedlich
kann das sein.
.NET und Datenbanken kennst du nicht aus. Von Vorteil
sind Erfahrungen in der GUI-Entwicklung.
Du verfügst über sehr gute Deutsch-Englisch-Kenntnisse,
dich zeichnet analytisches und unternehmerisches
Denken fällt dir leicht.
What? Okay, du schaust über Internet,
aber deiner Hand hinaus finde ich gut und am wichtigsten
Wunsch, du arbeitest gerne mit anderen zusammen,
bist zufällig offen gegenüber neuen Themen.
Anspruchsvolle, abwechslungsfreie Aufgaben
Geht klar, die Stellenanzeige.
Ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so die
in voller Vollendung, wo ich
sagen würde, oh ja, nice, sofort Bewerbung,
raus für alle, die da Bock drauf
haben. Ist
okay, ja.
Was haben wir hier? Pearljobs
Alter, wie viel
von diesen komischen
Jobseiten gibt es denn?
Moment, die haben auch den
Fanatic-Headshot-Controller.
Systemadministrator und Microsoft
Architekt...
Nee, Systemadministrator Microsoft
und Infrastructure.
Jetzt hab ich sie.
Administration unserer hybriden
Microsoft-Umgebung.
Office...
Jetzt fang ich auch schon an mit Office.
Microsoft 365, Windows Server,
Active Directory und etc.
Oh, das ist so viel Windows-Kram.
Das wird ja immer schlimmer, Mann.
Also für mich. Ich sag nicht, dass die
Stellenanzeige schlecht ist, nur für mich.
Ich steh da halt komplett auf Kriegsfuß
mit dem ganzen Microsoft-Shit.
Und den Betriebssystem...
Und den Betrieb der Systeme von VMware,
okay. Sie stellen den IT-Betrieb
unserer Infrastruktur, Monitoring, Patch,
Schwachstellen, Lifecycle-Management, ja okay,
hab doch mal einfach alles reingeschrieben,
sowie kontinuierliche Optimierung sicher.
Außerdem unterstützen sie unsere Mitarbeiter
und direkten Kolleginnen.
Wichtig, dass das alles MWD ist, nicht, dass man
irgendwie auf eine andere Idee kommen könnte.
Im Service-Management bei ihren
täglichen Herausforderungen.
Second- und Third-Level-Support.
Oh ja.
Warum nicht?
Die mit dem Steuermod rollen können.
Die verfügbar abgeschlossene
Ausbildung. Zudem sind sie sehr gut
vertraut mit aktueller Microsoft-Technologie.
Ja, da sind sie bei mir genau richtig.
Die Webseite
sieht auch ein bisschen wie von 2006 aus.
VMware
eigenständig
Okay.
Collegiales
Flare-Hierarchien, 30 Tage Urlaub,
Kostenzuschutz.
Kinderbetreuung, das ist natürlich nicht schlecht.
Möglichkeit zum Jobrad.
Ja, wer es braucht, ich hab mir das neue Fahrrad
einfach so gekauft. Kein Bock auf Jobrad.
Erhalten von Mitarbeiter Vergünstigung
auf Pearl-Produkt.
Ob es noch den Headshot-Controller gibt?
Möglichkeit zur Teilnahme
an Fitnessprogrammen.
Also,
ich muss sagen,
wer hat das gepostet?
Kodiak Husky
liest sich sehr 0815.
Kann man machen,
wenn man da Bock drauf hat, denke ich.
Also, springt einem jetzt
nichts entgegen, wo man sagen würde,
alter, bloß nicht.
Wenn man in der Microsoft-Welt unterwegs ist
und da Bock drauf hat,
liest sich halt sehr
ja,
sehr uninspiriert
0815-Stellenanzeige.
Es steht zumindest
immerhin drinne, was du machst, das finde ich schon mal gut.
Nicht so wie die einen vorhin, so nach dem Motto
wir suchen einen Entwickler. Für was, wissen wir
selber nicht, aber wir suchen einen Entwickler.
Achso, ne, die Frage
war ja, ob
2,5k brutto okay sind.
2,5k brutto
klingt enorm wenig.
Ich mein, das sind
30.000 im Jahr oder sowas.
Das ist ja nix.
Ne.
Ja, wenn man es jetzt mal richtig macht.
Ich kann auch nicht richtig rechnen, man.
Das ist, das ist, das ist
definitiv zu wenig.
Ich bekomme in Teilzeit auch mehr.
Und selbst das sollte man nicht unbedingt
als Maßstab dann nehmen. Also das ist auf jeden Fall
zu wenig.
Was passiert hier gerade im Chat?
Schickt ihr euch gerade Bewerbungen
gegenseitig zu oder was treibt
ihr hier?
Möchtest du lieber ein Struktogramm?
Ne, ne, okay, wenn ich die Auswahl
hätte und eins davon verwenden
muss, UML oder Struktogramm.
Wobei, das Ding
ist halt, UML und Struktogramm machen
unterschiedliche Sachen. UML ist
eher Klassenhierarchie und was die
unterschiedlichen Objekte an Methoden anbieten
und Struktogramm ist Anwendungslogik.
Beides für'n Arsch.
Ne, aber das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen wenig hier.
Kodiakaski, also da würde ich sagen,
also
da muss schon noch ein bisschen
mehr gehen.
Guck mal, was haben wir denn da?
Netzwerkadministrator.
Boah, das
flashbangt ja einen schon
wieder so richtig krass hier.
Achso. Okay.
Netzwerkadministrator für
Administration, Wartung, Überwachung
der LAN- und WLAN-Netzwerk
Infrastruktur.
Ja. Firewall.
Konzeption, Betrieb und
Segmentierung. Konzeption
in betriebnahen Dokumentationen. Schon
wieder? Was haben die alle nur
mit ihrer Dokumentation heute?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Alle wollen sie, dass
dokumentiert wird.
Es muss funktionieren, es muss nicht dokumentiert werden.
Der ständige Wachstum
der verfügbaren Systeme.
Troubleshooting, Analyse von technischen Problemen.
Okay, das liest sich auch sehr 0815.
Du hast ja dann abgeschlossen.
Okay, Standardsatz. Du hast bereits
Berufserfahrung in der Administration.
Ja. Du kennst dich aus
mit Cisco und D-Link
und optimalerweise mit
Seriously. Ja gut, im Cisco
Umfeld mögen die Zertifizierung und cloud-
erhaltung möglich.
Und die Cisco Zertifizierungen sind tatsächlich
nicht so easy, wie man denkt.
Also meine höchste Cisco Zertifizierung ist
die kleinste, die es gibt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es die noch gibt.
Gibt es CCNA noch?
Ich habe einen CCNA, aber der ist so alt,
der ist schon längst abgelaufen.
Außerdem halte ich von Zertifizierungen
nichts.
Er sagt doch, der ist abgelaufen.
Gutes System dokumentiert sich selbst.
Richtig, Niklas. Und noch besser,
ein gutes System funktioniert.
Wenn es funktioniert, muss es nicht dokumentiert sein.
Ist doch logisch. Du arbeitest zielstrebig,
strukturiert, ergebnisorientiert.
Weil du weißt,
worauf es in deinem Beruf ankommt.
Du bist Qualitäts-
und Verantwortungsbewusst.
Als Mitarbeiter im IT-Service bist du ausgesprochen
dienstleistungsorientiert.
Weiß ich mal nicht, was die mir damit sagen wollen.
Solche Sätze gibt es da öfters.
Ich glaube, die wollen dir damit verschlüsselt sagen,
du darfst nicht so schnell abgefuckt sein
von Anfragen von dummen Usern.
Du hast das Ziel immer im Blick und stehst gerne
in Kontakt mit anderen.
Dein verbindliches Auftreten
und...
Was ist denn ein verbindliches Auftreten?
Wie darf man sich das denn vorstellen?
Chat!
Tretet mal verbindlich auf,
dass ich weiß, was damit gemeint ist.
Nicht zu spät kommen, nicht rumdrucksen.
Also, wenn ich sage,
da arbeiten wir mit Hochdruck dran,
dann ist das gut, ja?
Da sind wir eh schon dran gerade,
bei all den Problemen.
Und wenn wir da nicht dran sind,
dann sind wir schon dran.
Und deine Kommunikation ist das i-Tüpfelchen,
das dich zum perfekten Kandidaten für diesen Job macht.
Wir bieten dir einen Arbeitsplatz.
Nice! Das ist aber nett von euch,
dass ihr mir den Arbeitsplatz bietet.
Ein hochwertiges, funktionales Arbeitsumfeld,
bei dem es dir an nichts fehlt.
Doch, ich wette mit euch,
mir fehlt es dort an was.
Und zwar an einem eigenen
Linux-Laptop.
Haben die bestimmt nicht.
Die Möglichkeit, dich beruflich
und persönlich auf eine hohe Ebene zu entfalten.
Was?
Die Möglichkeit, dich beruflich
und persönlich auf einer hohen Ebene
zu entfalten.
What?
Wie entfalte ich mich?
Also, okay.
Ich muss verbindlich aufdrehen, um mich
auf einer hohen Ebene zu entfalten.
Alles klar.
Das ist einfach nur Filler, ja.
Eine Vielzahl an Benefits
und Zusatzangeboten im Europa-Park.
The fuck?
Ist ja schön und gut, dass ich in Europa-Park
fahren kann, aber
ich kann auch selbst in Europa-Park fahren,
wenn ihr mir genug Kohle bezahlt.
Ach, Moment.
Das ist ein Job
im Europa-Park.
Das habe ich gar nicht gecheckt.
Okay, dann ergibt es
natürlich Sinn.
Profitiere von erstklassigen
Trainings und Fachseminaren
der Mac Academy.
Ja, auch.
15-jährige Stellenanzeige.
Jetzt nicht super toll,
nicht super schlecht.
Standard.
Jetzt nix drinne, wo ich gleich sagen würde,
boah, nee, bloß nicht.
Standard-Kram.
Sticht nicht groß hier raus.
Aber sonst noch.
Oh, die sehen aber hip aus.
Die müssen wir uns mal angucken.
Die sehen ja mal sowas von Hipster-modern aus.
Bank 11.
Was zum Teufel ist Bank 11?
Äh.
Okay, das ist ein bisschen so
wie Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof,
nur seriöser.
Mit Geldleihen.
Okay, also.
Für alle? Für euch.
Ja, natürlich. Ihr sagt mir, macht das alles
nur aus reiner Nächstenliebe, ist klar.
Das ist für die Leute
nach dem INSI-Modus, genau.
Aber immerhin,
eins muss man ihnen lassen,
sie haben recht fähige
so
Gestaltungsleute.
Das sind irgendwelche Stock-Fotos,
das sind keine Leute, die irgendwie auch nur
annähen, was mit der Bank da zu tun hat.
Oder das ist ja nicht mal ne Bank, oder?
Mit diesem Dienstleister da zu tun haben.
Aber immerhin, es hat ne gewisse,
auch wenn man das jetzt hier mehr Darkreader ausmacht,
es hat zumindest irgendwie ne gewisse
Identität, die Seite, ja.
Das ist schon ganz okay.
Die Gesichter sind auch viel größer, ja.
Die sind so glücklich, dass sie da sein können.
Achso.
Wollen wir mal gucken.
Nee, die kommen.
Tatsächlich,
nicht irgendwie auf den Bahamas
oder so.
Immerhin. Also, was wollen sie haben?
Sie wollen einen DevOps-Engineer haben.
Für alle, für euch, schnell, schlau
und digital.
Möchtest du die digitale Welt von morgen erobern?
Ja,
unbedingt.
Zu deinen Stärken
zählen ein kundenorientiertes
Moment. Aber nicht verbindlich,
ne.
Und es ist auch die Frage, ob man sich da auf
der höchsten Ebene entfalten kann.
Als die in der letzten
Stellenanzeige stand, war schon ein bisschen
viel Filler-Text drinnen.
Und strukturiertes und selbständiges
Arbeiten. Dann kommen
jetzt zur Bank 11.
Oder ist es vielleicht
sogar Bank 11?
Eine der besten Autobanken Deutschlands
mit über 400 Mitarbeiter
innen. Bei uns hast
du die Möglichkeit, IT-Lösungen mit
und weiter zu entwickeln und Impulse zu setzen.
In einem engagierten, achtköpfigen,
ganze acht Leute,
achso, naja, wird nicht die einzige IT-Abteilung
dort sein.
Oder Team in der IT-Abteilung.
Was ist eine Autobank?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Sie suchen einen DevOps-Engineer, also quasi,
mal gucken, das wird ja was, was genau auf
mich passt. Das heißt, das
müsste mich ansprechen.
Deine spannenden Aufgaben mit
Betreuung der operativen Projekte
und deren Entwicklung.
Bereitstellung gemeinsamer Weiterentwicklung
unserer Continuous Delivery Pipeline
sowie der Cloud-Umgebung. Passt gut dazu.
Unterstützung
beim Betrieb unserer bestehenden Infrastruktur
in einer...
Ja gut, es ist Business Enterprise.
Und gerade im Finanzdienstleisterumfeld
ist Java super etabliert.
Unsere bestehende Infrastruktur
in einer Java-basierten Multitier-Umgebung.
Was auch immer das in dem Kontext
bedeutet.
Multitier, damit ist ja normalerweise
gemeint, du kannst da verschiedene Clients
drin anlegen und sowas, aber...
Oder meinen die mit Multitier-Umgebung,
dass du verschiedene Umgebungs-Stages hast?
Sowas wie Test
und
Integration oder so und Live
und...
Ich weiß es nicht. Dokumentation
der operativen Prozesse... Schon wieder!
Leute, ich...
Es wird echt langsam Zeit für das
Wubblos-Zertifikat.
Was die immer alle mit ihrer Dokumentation
wollen. Das meinte ja, wie viel Geld man damit sparen könnte,
wenn die alle das...
Den...
Die Wubbler-Skalierung...
Skalierungsmethode verwenden würden.
Teilnahme an Release-Prozessen.
Warum wird denn das so fett geschrieben?
Meinen die damit,
nachts wird deployten, du musst dabei sein?
Das lese ich jetzt hier
nicht raus, aber kann damit gemeint sein.
Projektsprache ist
Deutsch!
Bäm! Erste Praxiserfahrung
mit Linux-Systemen.
Jo, das ist
sicherlich nicht verkehrt in dem Umfeld.
Sowie im DevOps-Umfeld Java-Anwendung
auf Spring Boot Docker Elastic Stack.
Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass
sie tatsächlich produktive Sachen
mit Docker laufen haben. Nicht, dass man
das nicht machen könnte, aber
vielleicht nicht zwangsläufig die beste
Idee. Aber kann
man machen. Gerade wenn man nicht
so viel Infrastruktur hat
und es nicht sonderlich hoch verfügbar sein muss,
dann... Ja.
Ich gehe auch davon aus, dass es
irgendein Managed Kubernetes ist
bei irgendeinem Cloud-Anbieter.
Wo es dann am Ende
drin läuft.
Ja, Elasticsearch.
Wie heißt das ganze Zeug da bei Elasticsearch?
Das besteht doch aus mehreren Teilen.
Ich vergesse aber, wie das heißt. Das ist nicht nur
Elasticsearch. Es ist noch
ähm... Kibana?
Kibana, genau. Kibana?
Es ist der
Elk Stack. Elasticsearch?
Kibana? Und was ist das
El?
Logstash!
Genau, ja. Das ist der Chat.
Chat. Es gab
einfach schon zu viele Prime-Subs heute.
Der Chat hat
zu viel Gehirn. Natürlich kann man
nie zu viel Gehirn haben.
Radiantracer, danke für den Sub. Sorry, falls ich
übersehen habe. Schon zwei Stunden her.
Kekwait.
SikJuicySJ
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Jetzt ist...
Megamind, ja.
Der Chat ist einfach zu schlau für Twitch.
Also jetzt mal ohne Mist, gell.
Wenn ich auf Twitch so unterwegs bin und mir da die anderen
Sachen angucke, muss ich schon ehrlich sagen,
ihr seid mit Sicherheit
vielleicht jetzt
nicht unbedingt der most
high IQ Chat, aber auf jeden
Fall Top 5% high IQ Chat
auf Twitch.
FourYearOldChinese, dankeschön für den
Sub. Pfeiffer Chat.
GamersElite.
PogSubscription, dankeschön. Oh Leute, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das
heute alles schaffe. Ich hab noch so viel auf. Ich hab noch mal viel
Zeit. Reicht jetzt für heute.
Hebt euch für den nächsten Stream auf.
Ihr könnt das übrigens auch in normalen Streams posten
oder sowas. Sowas zwischendurch angucken kann man
immer machen. Okay, also was haben wir sonst noch?
Praxiserfahrung in Linux-Systemen.
DevOpsumfeld, Java, Springboard.
Erste Kenntnisse, zum Beispiel im Bereich
Continuous Delivery Prozesse.
Okay, die machen GitLab, äh, ne.
GitLab CI heißt es nicht.
GitLab Actions gibt es nicht.
GitHub Actions und GitLab CI.
IT Security
Configur... Was? Und? Oder?
Configuration API.
What?
Das hat jemand geschrieben, der nicht weiß,
was er da schreibt, glaube ich.
Was ist Configuration
API? Was soll das
in diesem Kontext bedeuten?
Da steht
IT Security.
Anzeige.
Abmahnung. Kenntnisse in einer
Konfigurationsmanagement-Software wie
zum Beispiel Terraform sind von Vorteil. Jo.
Terraform ist auch das einzige, was Sinn macht.
Einfach mit Abstand
das verbreitetste, hat die meisten
Plugins, unterstützt die meisten Provider
und ist ganz
passabel eigentlich auch
zu benutzen.
Wenn's mich auch regelmäßig abfuckt, aber
das würden wahrscheinlich andere Lösungen auch.
Ich würde ja gerne mal ein bisschen mehr
Crossplane ausprobieren.
Aber das ist quasi
Terraform für Kubernetes, um's mal
ganz in einem Satz zu sagen.
Trifft's nicht
genau, aber...
dass ihr euch was darunter vorstellen könnt.
Ich würde gerne mal ein bisschen Crossplane ausprobieren.
Was mich ein bisschen abschreckt ist,
das scheint mir einen super krassen
Einstiegs-Lernkurve zu haben und
es hat irgendwie so eine ganz
komische Philosophie, dass
Änderungen ohne jegliche Prüfung
immer sofort angewandt werden.
Man könnte jetzt natürlich sagen, die sind
Wubbler Certified, weil wenn man
keine Fehler in den Änderungen drin hat,
dann können die auch immer sofort
applied werden, weil dann
ist ja alles immer richtig.
Vielleicht machen die's auch einfach
nur korrekt. Du kannst ja auch
mal was hückeln.
Das ist das
Apple-Ding, ja?
Interesse an Container- und Cloud-Technologien,
abgeschlossene Ausbildung als Fachinformatiker
oder vergleichbare Qualifikation,
leistungsgereiche Urlaubstage, mobiles
Arbeiten, Altersvorsorge, Kinder...
Nicht verkehrt.
Viele Aktionen, Vergünstigungen
mit unseren Bistro-Getränken. Das ist immer nice,
wenn's dort vor Ort was zu fressen gibt.
Sehr nice. Schnell
und schlau digital.
Welcome LGBTQ
und BIPOC.
Okay, jetzt hört aber meine Kenntnis
auf. Da kann ich mir nur was darunter vorstellen.
Aber was ist BIPOC?
Oder
BIPOC? Black?
Black?
Vielleicht?
Black Indigene People
of Color. Aha.
Okay. Das ist nicht neu, mag
sein, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Also...
Langsam ist auch mal gut mit
Abkürzungen eher.
Ich hätte auch gerne
eigene Abkürzungen.
Was ist IT-interessiertes Kellerkind?
Kann man da auch irgendwas dafür machen?
Ich mach was mit Computer, das braucht auch
eine eigene Abkürzung.
Ja, das eh! Das sind das... Hä, warum wird
das gar nicht gepostet?
Alter, das...
Das... Twitch blockt das mittlerweile.
Guck mal.
Twitch hat das mittlerweile geblockt.
Du bist ein alter, weißer Mann.
Das musste ich ihm erst explizit freigeben.
Ja, ist auch so.
Jaja.
Das musste ich ihm explizit
freigeben. Es ist noch schlimmer, Leute.
Es ist noch schlimmer.
Ich bin alt,
weiß,
männlich,
heterosexuell,
kein Veganer, also omnivor, wie man
das so schön nennt.
Was bin ich denn noch?
Was eigentlich...
Was eigentlich ganz furchtbar schlimm ist heutzutage?
Ähm...
Deutsch auch noch, ja?
Ne, blond bin ich nicht.
Privilegiert.
Stimmt, ich hab auch noch... Fuck, ich hab auch noch ein Haus, Mann.
Nicht sportlich.
Da wäre ich mir
aber nicht so sicher.
Tesla-Fahrer? Nein, nein, nein.
Tesla-Fahrer nicht. Aber Elektro-Auto-Fahrer.
Das stimmt.
Blaue Augen? Ne, auch nicht.
Aber...
Das ist Prof. Das ist...
Das, dass ich ein Elektro-Auto habe, ist, glaube ich,
das einzige, was ich auf der
Pro-Seite hab, oder?
Alles andere ist ja heute
so negativ vorbelastet.
Bei manchen Leuten.
Man könnte auch einfach sagen,
das andere ist einfach normal.
Boah.
Äh...
Ich hab keinen extra Stromanbieter für die Wallbox.
Gut, also, weiter.
Also, ich finde die Stellenanzeige nicht verkehrt.
Der Inhalt, und das muss man ja
bei vielen Stellenanzeigen... Jetzt muss man ja schon
mal lobend hervorheben.
Der Inhalt deckt sich mit dem,
zumindest zum größten Teil, was ich mir
unter dieser Berufsbezeichnung vorstellen würde.
Das ist ja schon mal was.
Ich finde das nicht verkehrt.
Dass da Rechtschreibfehler in der Stellenanzeige sind,
so wort, mich juckt's jetzt ehrlich gesagt
nicht. Könnt natürlich schon da reininterpretieren.
Vielleicht bisschen so
Lack of Qualitätssicherung.
Das war auch ein Satz, oder?
Ihr wisst, was ich mein.
Arbeitstage Montag bis Freitag.
Ja.
Ich denke,
das ist gar nicht so übel hier.
Ob die natürlich nicht so übel bezahlen, das
weiß ich nicht.
Was haben wir denn als nächstes?
Wir müssen jetzt mal von dort anfangen, weil
die warten schon ganz lange hier, die Leute.
Das bei Amazon guck ich mir
jetzt nicht an.
DevOps Engineer, Systemadministrator.
Das sind nämlich die Sachen, die ganz am Anfang vom Stream
gepostet wurden.
DEMV
Systems.
DevOps Engineer, Systemadministrator,
MWD in Hamburg
oder Remote.
Stimmt, die brauchen wir ja auch noch. Wir haben noch Zeit.
Also, sie suchen...
Ja.
Find ich okay, weil ganz ehrlich,
die meisten DevOps-Leute
kommen aus dem Bereich und das hat viele
Überschneidungen. Also ich kenn mehr
DevOps-Leute, die aus dem Bereich kommen als
ehemalige Anwendungsentwickler, die
das jetzt machen. Außerdem,
DevOps ist im Prinzip der neue
Admin. Klingt einfach cooler.
So, als
DevOps Engineer bla bla bla bla bla
du optimierst
und hältst
unsere Serverinfrastruktur auf dem neuesten
Stand. Das ist nice, das ist genau
das, was ich mir darunter vorstelle.
DevOps ist halt kein Ausbildungsberuf.
Ja, Systemadministrator auch nicht.
Du kannst im Prinzip Fachinformatiker
für Systemintegration werden und danach
gucken, dass du möglichst viel Ahnung
hast und dann in dem Bereich arbeiten, was dir
gefällt.
Also, es ist wirklich eine
Besonderheit, die wir heute im Stream hatten,
dass wir jemanden hatten, der einen Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration sucht.
Das ist so besonders, dass ich
ernsthaft davon ausgegangen bin, es geht
hier um eine Azubi-Stelle, es geht um eine Ausbildungsstelle.
Gings aber gar nicht.
Du optimierst und hältst unsere Serverinfrastruktur
Dabei setzt du bei der Konferenz
auf Automatisierung mit Puppet.
Puppet ist keine gute Idee mehr heutzutage.
Seriously. Du findest immer schwieriger
Leute, die Puppet
Erfahrung haben.
Und Puppet
findest du sehr schwer, Ansible findest du
deutlich mehr. Nicht wie Sand am Meer,
aber deutlich mehr.
Natürlich haben die das Problem,
die haben bestimmt ihre gesamte Infrastruktur
in Puppet am Start,
aber es ist wirklich schwierig, da Leute zu finden, Leute.
Durch das Zusammenspiel
von Monitoring und Alerting
sorgst du für eine
hohe Verfügbarkeit und schnelle Problemerkennung.
Du integrierst
Software in unsere Multicloud Umgebung
bei Hetzner und AWS.
Nice!
Das ist doch mal eine sinnvolle Kombination.
Muss ich jetzt mal sagen.
Du machst bei AWS,
wenn du irgendwie einen der tausend
Managed Sachen dort brauchst,
wenn du einfach nur eine simple
VM brauchst,
mit vielleicht einem Loadbalancer davor,
machst du Hetzner.
Da bist du mit Sicherheit
auch eine ganze Ecke billiger
dabei.
Ich schick dir in Bewerbung
den Rabattcode mit.
Das wär's jetzt mal.
Also,
ich sag's jetzt nochmal,
ich such keinen Job aktuell.
Das ist just for fun hier.
Infrastructure as Code
setzt du via Terraform um.
Genau, das ist gut.
Das einzige sinnvolle Tool dafür.
Es gibt schon noch mehr,
aber das mit Abstand verbreitetste
und bekannteste ist Terraform.
Zusammen mit den Teams entwickelst du
dieses und Projekte.
Du hast
mit Linux,
insbesondere Debian,
kommst du gut zurecht.
Pluspunkt, Leute.
Die setzen eine ordentliche Distribution ein
und es kommt nicht einmal Windows
und Microsoft Shit in dieser Stellenanzeige vor.
Sehr nice.
Shit und Shithub
sowie
CI, CD via GitHub Actions
auch nice.
Was die GitHub Actions benutzen.
Ich mag GitHub Actions.
Von allen
Systemen,
die ich bisher benutzt habe,
was so Automatisierungsbildgeschichten
angeht, finde ich
GitHub Actions am angenehmsten.
Ich hab natürlich auch bei weitem
nicht alles ausprobiert.
Ich kenn den Klassiker, ich kenn sowas wie Jenkins,
ich kenn GitLab CI und ich kenn
GitHub Actions. Und ich glaube,
das war's.
Und da muss ich sagen, so von
dem Gesamtpaket finde ich GitHub Actions
einfach am schönsten.
Container, insbesondere Docker, sind bei uns
immer mehr im Einsatz.
Konfiguration Puppet.
Englisch.
Wenn du dich mit MariaDB auskennst,
ist das ein Pluspunkt, aber kann man...
Ja.
Mich persönlich spricht das hier an.
Wo sind die? Hamburg.
Ob natürlich jetzt der Laden wirklich gut ist,
ob das Gehalt taugt,
keine Ahnung.
Also mich würden diese Parts hier
durchaus ansprechen.
AWS ist die Cloud-Umgebung oder der...
Sorry Leute, nicht Cloud-Anbieter.
Ich muss ja meinen eigenen...
meinem eigenen Advice followen.
Hyperscaler.
AWS ist der
Hyperscaler, mit dem ich mich am wenigsten
auskenne. Azure
kenn ich mich ganz gut aus. Google kenn ich mich
mittlerweile sogar besser aus, weil ich
das letzte Jahr über...
Azure hab ich schon wieder jede Menge vergessen.
Google mach ich das letzte Jahr über täglich.
Google Cloud.
AWS kenn ich mich am wenigsten mit aus.
Bei den drei großen Hyperscalern.
Auch ein Rechtschreibfehler?
Echt? Wo denn?
Also mich spricht's an.
Auch NoBullshit, kurz und knackig,
alles gut.
Könnte mir nur noch toppen, aber er könnte
einiges noch toppen, aber eine Sache wäre
natürlich gut, wenn gleich mal drinnen stehen würde,
wie viel Kohle man erwarten kann.
Hast du eine Empfehlung? Das ist eine gute Frage.
Hast du eine Empfehlung, wie man als Dev am besten
in Cloud-Themen einsteigt? Ja.
Bau Docker-Container.
Erstmal
unabhängig von Cloud.
Bau mal Docker-Container.
Containerisiere mal deine Anwendung.
Da lernst du
sehr viel dabei.
Was dir auch später was bringt,
wenn das denn beispielsweise mal in irgendeinem
Managed Kubernetes läuft oder so.
Containerisiere mal deine eigene Anwendung.
Und zwar gescheit, ja.
Also nicht, dass da ein 600 MB großes Image
rauskommt, sondern Multistage
Build, das am Ende wirklich nur ein Image rauskommt,
was, keine Ahnung,
minimal slim Debian ist.
Kein Alpine. Ich persönlich bin kein Alpine-Fan.
Habe ich schon oft genug gesagt.
Ich finde, auf die paar MBs kommt es dann
auch nicht an.
20 MB, 30 MB großes
Image.
Geht bestimmt auch kleiner.
Containerisiere mal deine Anwendung.
Das ist ein guter Einstiegspunkt.
Hat jetzt nicht direkt was mit Cloud zu tun,
ist aber Voraussetzung
für viele Sachen in der Cloud.
Und ansonsten
musst du dich ein bisschen mit Linux beschäftigen,
weil das meiste
in der Cloud ist Linux-based.
Nicht, dass es kein Windows gibt,
aber glücklicherweise machen die Leute
da einen größeren Bogen drum.
Wie lernt man am besten Kubernetes
einfach mal machen? Minikube.
Minikube ist mit Abstand
das Einfachste.
Minikube.
Start.
Und schon hast du ein Kubernetes zum
Einstellen lokal laufen auf deiner Kiste.
Das geht auch nur unter Linux btw.
Ich habe schon eine Weile nicht mehr gestartet,
deswegen lädt das ja erstmal den ganzen Shit runter.
Arch btw.
Aber das geht auch unter anderem
Linux-Distribution, das muss nicht unbedingt Arch
sein. Geht bestimmt auch unter
Gentoo irgendwie nach 2 Stunden kompilieren.
Guck hier.
Zack. Jetzt hat er die neuesten Kubernetes
Sachen runtergeladen.
Jetzt erstellt er einen Container
mit Kubernetes Control Plane
und wenn das dann irgendwann mal
gestartet ist
Minikube ist auf
Windows
mit
VM Backend wahrscheinlich dann.
Und jetzt kannst du sagen
kubectl get pods-a
und siehst du, hast du einen lokalen Kubernetes Cluster.
Der noch am starten ist, aber du hast
einen lokalen Kubernetes Cluster.
Und kannst
jetzt damit rumbasteln.
Was du damit nicht ausprobieren kannst
sind natürlich irgendwelche Cloud Anbieter
oder irgendwelche
ja wo es wirklich um hoch verfügbare
Sachen geht mit
Rolling Updates über mehrere Nodes
und sowas.
Da brauchst du was anderes für, aber
um mal so die grundsätzlichen Sachen dir
anzugucken und damit auch mal
was drauf zu deployen und so. Minikube.
Tomux, das kann ich dir auch empfehlen.
Minikube. Beste. Und wenn du fertig bist
sagst du Minikube delete und ist wieder alles rückstandslos
weg. So.
Also. Eins.
Eins machen wir noch hier. Wo ist hier? Ja.
Für unsere Fußballstelz
Leute.
Oh. Mein Auge.
Das ist. Leute.
Der Hintergrund. Das ist kein weißer
Hintergrund. Das ist ein weißes Bild.
Im Hintergrund.
Deswegen funktioniert der Darkreader da nicht drauf.
Painschamp.
Alter.
IT Systemadministration.
Administrator. System Engineer.
Schwerpunkt IT Security.
Ein Weg. Ein Ziel.
Eine Leidenschaft.
Das ist ein Bild oder?
Oder auch nicht?
Ja. Doch. Das ist ein Bild oder?
Wir haben eine über hundertjährige Tradition.
Ja. Fußball halt.
Du fungierst als erster Ansprechpartner
für IT Security.
Moment.
Du fungierst als erster Ansprechpartner
für unsere IT Security Partner.
Hä?
Ach für irgendwelche Pentester Dudes und sowas.
Ja. Das verstehe ich auch nicht genau.
Du steuerst die Zusammenarbeit mit unseren
IT Operations Center.
Hä?
Dann verstehe ich die Stelle auch nicht so ganz.
Du bist an Konzeption, Weiterentwicklung sowie Umsetzung
Schutz...
Einsatzbereitschaft
an Heimspieltagen unserer Mannschaft.
Was?
Meinen die damit
ich muss Fußballfan
sein und mir das angucken?
Oder meinen die ich habe Bereitschaft
falls was kaputt geht?
An Heimspieltagen.
Ich verstehe nicht genau was sie damit meinen.
Du musst Würstchen verkaufen.
Mehrjährige Berufserfahrung
als IT-Administrator. Du bist ein Allround-Talent
innerhalb der IT.
Idealerweise. Man nennt sowas
heute übrigens nicht mehr Allround-Talent.
Ich habe letztens auch gehört, dass man als
Buzzword da heutzutage verwendet
Check of All Trades.
Weil Allround-Talent
klingt zu noobisch.
Check of All Trades.
Es gibt
für jeden Kack irgendwelche Wörter mittlerweile.
Idealerweise
bringst du gute Kenntnisse im
IT-Security Umfeld.
Ich würde sagen das ist Pflicht oder?
Als IT-Administrat mit dem Schwerpunkt Security.
Das Ding ist halt
Das ist halt
super umfangreich.
Was genau
wollt ihr denn von mir?
Also sinnbildlich gesprochen.
Nicht direkt von mir persönlich.
Was wollt ihr denn
von dem Bewerber? IT-Security Umfeld.
Ich habe mal mit Nmap
ein paar Server gescannt.
Gute Kenntnisse im IT-Security Umfeld.
Fundierte Kenntnisse
von verschiedenen IT-Security Tools.
Ich kann einen Curl machen.
Leistungsorientiertes und
userzentriertes Denken und Handeln.
Gute Kenntnisse in Collaboration Tools.
Welche denn?
Es gibt ja nur eins auf der Welt.
Und wenn ich das kenne, ist es gut.
Kommunikationsstärke, Teamfähigkeit,
Verantwortungsbewusstsein.
Gutes Arbeitsklima mit einem dynamischen Umfeld.
Mit motivierten, sympathischen Kollegen.
Bereitstellung von kostenfreien Getränken.
Freikarte für Heimspiel.
Okay.
Für Fußballfans ist das bestimmt mega nice.
Vergünstigung in der
In der was?
Fohlens
Fohlen
Fohlensportsbar.
Fanshop-Rabatte.
Vergünstigtes Fahrradleasing.
Betriebecamp.
Hybrides Arbeiten.
Ich glaube für Fußballfans bestimmt nice.
Für mich sind ein bisschen
wenig Details drin.
Einfach mal so ein paar
Dinger hingeschrieben.
Collaboration Tools, IT-Security, Umfeld.
Ja was genau
stellt ihr euch denn vor?
Ein bisschen spezifischer darf es schon sein.
Leon, dankeschön für den Sub.
Mich spricht es jetzt nicht so an.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Vielleicht für die krassen Fußballfans unter euch.
Du wolltest doch was mit C-Sharp globale Variablen zeigen.
Ne.
Wenn derjenige, der das gefragt hat,
das letzte Mal wieder da ist.
Und bis jetzt war er noch nicht wieder da.
Oder bist du das gewesen?
Meinst du?
Ne, das zeige ich, wenn derjenige,
der das gefragt hat, da ist.
Oder will es noch jemand wissen?
Warte, hat keinen Sinn,
wenn ich das jetzt zeige und er nicht da ist.
Ihr benutzt Jyra?
Ich bin auch ein großer Jyra-Fan.
Leon Pock Subscription.
Ich glaube, ich habe nichts übersehen.
Die hatten wir schon.
Okay, eine können wir uns so angucken.
Welche gucken wir uns dann an?
Stattessen.
Okay, die sind immer lustig, meistens.
So öffentliche Sachen.
Was entscheidest du eigentlich, was in welchem Browser
gemacht wird?
Intuitiv, spontan.
Webex, Painschamp.
Elf TV, das war nicht so viel.
Wir gucken da jedes Mal nach
und stellen immer fest, das ist nicht so nice.
Schwerpunkt Security.
Stattessen.
Was ist denn das da vorne eigentlich?
Das sieht aus wie Haarwaschmittel.
So Shampoo.
Aber was ist das?
Was sehe ich da?
Für Textmarker ist es doch
viel zu groß.
Oder ist es einfach nur
Perspektive?
Das Lieblingswort
aller Flacherdler.
Perspektive.
Was sind Textmarker?
Textmarker, oder?
Bisschen zu kleines Fop.
Tatsächlich, die sind das.
Ja.
Ihr habt Recht.
Okay, Teilzeit erlaubt.
Das ESH, das was?
Essen? Systemhaus?
Ist als ein...
Okay, bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla.
Mit ihrem Einsatz
werden sie unsere Abteilung
Rechenzentrumsbetrieb,
die mit ihren Teams gemeinsam
zusammenarbeiten.
Rechenzentrum, Server, Datenbank,
Dienst- und Bürokommunikation.
Okay.
Also einfach für alles, ja?
Rechenzentrum, Server, Datenbanken,
Dienste und Büro, also einfach alles.
Ihr zukünftiger Arbeitsort
befindet sich im
E.T.C.
Carré und dem angrenzenden
Gebäude...
Wen juckt's?
Ja.
Dich hätten wir heute öfter schon gebraucht,
aber das ist ja auch ein
sehr gutes Zeichen.
Sie verstärken die Abteilung Rechenzentrumsbetrieb
bei diesen Aufgaben.
Okay.
Anministration und Weiterentwicklung von komplexen IT-Syklen
ist benötigt im Bereich Endpoint Protection.
Aha.
Any 7 TV Mods?
Die Mode am Start.
Das ist nice.
Ja.
Das klingt super allgemein.
Endpoint Protection.
Proaktives Monitoring.
Bewertung von
IT-Security-Vorfällen sowie
Initierung von Gegenmaßnahmen.
Ja, das braucht die Stadt Essen
tatsächlich. Gab's da nicht vor nicht allzu
langer Zeit mal richtig Probleme,
gerade auch bei der Stadt Essen?
Mit irgendwelchen
Ransomware Trojaner
Geschiss?
Da war doch irgendwas.
Ja...
Ich bekomme da auch keine Vibes
in der Stellenanzeige.
Zusammenarbeiten mit
prozessverantwortlichen Endpoint-Nutzern zur
Erarbeitung von Verbesserungsoptionen
in bestehenden Infrastrukturen.
Das ist super allgemein alles.
Abgeschlossener Verwaltungslehrgang 2
mit dem Schwerpunkt IT.
Okay.
Damit fallen schon mal 99,9%
oder
99,99%
der Leute, die dafür in Frage kommen,
raus.
Wer zum Teufel hat einen abgeschlossenen
Verwaltungslehrgang 2?
Wenn du nicht gerade schon zufällig
dort irgendwie gearbeitet hast und eigentlich nur
intern wechseln willst.
Damit werde ich halt einfach keine Leute finden.
Fachkenntnisse in der Sistieradministration
im Bereich Betriebssysteme
Windows, Linux, Protokolle,
Netzwerkinfrastruktur.
Wer hat denn diesen...
Wer schreibt denn diesen Scheiß
immer, Mann?
Man, Windows, Linux lass ich mir doch gefallen.
Protokolle, Mann.
Was jetzt?
Wer schreibt diesen Scheiß immer?
Das ist so schlecht, Mann.
Kein Wunder, dass die keine Leute finden.
Und wenn sie Leute finden, keine fähigen Leute,
da wunderst du dich echt nicht mehr.
Was das jetzt mit dem Titel
zu tun hat?
Systemadministrator, dann musst du dich mit Protokollen,
mit allen Protokollen, muss ich auskennen.
Kenntnisse im Bereich Security
Endpoint Protection,
EDR und XDR.
Okay.
Da haben sie mich jetzt erwischt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wofür EDR steht.
EDR?
Könnte das auch für Endpoint Protection
stehen?
Endpoint
Protection?
Ah, Moment.
Endpoint Detection and Response.
Alles klar.
Und was ist
XDR?
XDing.
XD.
Extended Detection
and Response.
Ah, ein Holistic Security Solution.
Alles klar.
Auf Deutsch heißt das
Holistic bedeutet so etwas wie ganzheitlich.
Aber
Holistic Approach klingt natürlich
viel geiler.
Schwachstellen und Patchmanagement
beziehungsweise die Bereitschaft, diese
kurzfristig zu erwärmen.
PowerShell.
Ganz ehrlich, die Stellenanzeige ist so schlecht.
So
schlecht.
Die müssen sich echt nicht wundern, wenn sie da
keinen Finden für haben.
Kohle gibt es wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Weil das immer schwer zu sagen ist, wie man da Steuern
bezahlen muss und sonst was.
Naja.
Ah, Moment. Moment. Hahaha.
Chebated.
Chebated, overrated, outdated.
Das ist ja diese
Steuern.
Das geht aber eigentlich schon mal ganz gut
klar, oder?
Je nachdem wie das mit den Steuern ist.
Wobei das Aufsteigen,
das ist ja immer so ganz komisch. Du musst mindestens
ein Jahr haben.
Dann musst du hier alles das, was
du da vorhast, plus das, plus das,
plus das. Also
nach 5 Jahren in Stufe 5, das erreichst du
irgendwie nach 20 Jahren dort oder so.
Ich kann diese öffentlichen Sachen
immer sehr schlecht einschätzen,
wie gut und schlecht das ist.
Sind es 12 Gehälter, 13, 14?
Wenn es nur 12 sind,
ist das jetzt sicherlich
nicht geil.
Ah, das sind dann...
Das ist jetzt nicht so
der Wahnsinn. Das ist schon besser.
Aber auch nicht so
wahnsinnig doll.
Das könntest du halt rausreißen,
wenn du nicht so viele Steuern bezahlen musst.
Weiß ich nicht, wie das da ist.
Aber selbst mal 13 ist nicht so
krass jetzt.
Ja, also
ich kann das immer schwer einschätzen.
Wahrscheinlich ist die Bezahl...
Also das hier ist auf jeden Fall nicht geil.
Brauchst du ein Studium?
Nee, brauchst du nicht.
Tut auch das hier.
So, ohne Beamtung.
Okay, dann bezahlst du ganz normal Steuern.
Ja, Stufenaufstieg ist automatisch
nach 12 Monaten, aber
wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe,
ähm...
funktioniert das ja folgendermaßen.
Du steigst automatisch
nach 12... Du steigst automatisch auf
nach einem Jahr
hierin. Okay.
Dann musst du quasi 3 Jahre
dadrin haben.
Also nee, da musst du 3 Jahre
da musst du 3 Jahre darin
haben. Da musst du 3 Jahre
dadrin sein. Also das addiert
sich. Also am Ende
musst du da irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 15 Jahre
oder so dabei sein, dass du da irgendwo landest.
Und in 15 Jahren
ist das halt auch nicht mehr geil. Und jetzt auch schon nicht
so wahnsinnig doll.
Also reich wirst du
da nicht von. Das liest sich nicht.
Steht doch da. Du steigst
automatisch nach dem ersten Jahr auf. Da rein.
So. Dann brauchst du mindestens 3
Jahre das da. Okay, vielleicht
kannst du auch direkt dadrin einsteigen.
Aber spätestens hier, und da
fängt es dann langsam mal interessant zu werden, musst
du mindestens 3 Jahre
das da haben. Danach musst du mindestens
4 Jahre das da haben. Und danach musst du mindestens
5 Jahre das da haben. Also das
addiert sich dann auf jeden Fall zusammen. Das heißt, du
kommst dann hier schon mal auf 12 Jahre.
Du musst mindestens
12 Jahre dabei sein.
Dass es ganz
brauchbar ist, was rauskommt. Weil selbst das
ist jetzt nicht super irgendwie
Advanced
Gaskohle für
in 12 Jahren.
Okay. Aber
ganz davon abgesehen, das ist
nicht netto. Nein. Da musst du noch Steuern drauf
bezahlen. Netto wär das nice.
Ist es aber nicht.
Naja, warum? 6000 Euro
netto? Kannst du dich nicht beschweren?
Ich weiß nicht, was der Chat für Anforderungen
hat, aber das fände ich okay.
Und selbst 4000 Euro
netto ist sicherlich nicht schlecht.
Das ist ungefähr
ungefähr das,
was ich
mit 4 Tage Woche verdiene
im Monat. Umgefähr.
Also was ungefähr mit 4 Tage Woche und
Berufsbereitschaft bei mir im Monat
auf dem Konto ankommt. Da ist aber
der Bonus noch nicht dabei.
Also das ist
und ich verdiene
nicht schlecht. Also das ist
schon in Ordnung, wenn es das wäre.
Kannst du nix sagen.
Also da hat wahrscheinlich
die meisten Leute in Deutschland weniger.
Also Nico, da kann man sich
finde ich echt in Ordnung.
Finanzen sagt viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Ja, es ist ungefähr in dem Dreh.
Es sind
ich müsste jetzt in die App gucken.
Es sind irgendwie
3400 Euro plus
die Berufsbereitschaft Sachen
und da kommt halt noch immer ganz viel Kleinscheiß
dabei. Also es ist wahrscheinlich
ein Minim... Also mit Bonus ist es
auf jeden Fall mehr, aber wahrscheinlich ist es...
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich müsste jetzt bei mir in
der App gucken. Ich müsste vor allem mal
wieder ordentliche Zeiterfassung
machen für meine Berufsbereitschaft, dass ich die
Kohle auch bekomme.
Hat ein Arbeitgeber noch... Ja,
das ist ein riesengroßer Laden.
Riesengroße Versicherung in Frankfurt
mit zig
Standorten in Deutschland.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
die Stellenanzeige hier ist
Schrott. Würde ich mich nie im Leben
darauf bewerben.
Richtig Schrott.
Wer das immer schreibt bei den Behörden,
weiß auch nicht... Die müssen sich wirklich
nicht wundern, dass die keine Leute finden.
Wie gesagt, wenn sie Leute finden, dann finden sie keine fähigen
Leute. Dann haben sie demnächst wieder
Ransomware
Verschlüsselungs-Gramm.
Bettke, richtig!
Jetzt ist Bettke-Time
angesagt. Was ist deine
Meinung nach die
best... Moment, ich geh noch nicht
ins Bett. Ich muss eben... Irgendwas wollte ich oben noch
noch auf irgendwas oben eingehen.
Ich muss gleich nochmal durchcrollen.
Was sind deiner Meinung nach die bestbezahlten
IT-Jobs, wo es auch wirklich viele von gibt?
AI-Engineer,
das ist ja aktuell letztendlich das Mainstream-Ding.
Ja. Clown-Engineer,
Projektleiter, Solution-Architekt.
Keine Ahnung. Da musst du dir
irgendwelche Statistikseiten angucken.
Heiser hat jedes Jahr sowas.
Stackoverflow hat auch eine Umfrage.
Das weiß ich nicht aus dem Kopf.
Keine Ahnung.
Ganz ehrlich, ich würde nicht danach gehen,
was der bestbezahlte Job ist.
Ich würde mir was suchen in dem Bereich,
auf den ich Bock hab.
Du kannst in jedem IT-Bereich
gut Kohle verdienen, wenn du Ahnung
davon hast. Wenn du was kannst, was
eben gebraucht wird
und was nicht viele Leute können.
Und das heißt meistens nicht,
ich kann mich mal auf dem Linux-System
einloggen und drei Befehle eintippen oder ich kann
in Windows drei Sachen klicken, sondern
du hast wirklich tiefgreifend Ahnung
von irgendwas. Ah gut,
SAP ist die Lizenz zum Gelddrucken, das stimmt.
Und die Chance, dass du tiefgreifend
von was Ahnung hast,
vielleicht auch nach ein paar Jahren,
ist umso höher, wenn es was ist,
was dich persönlich interessiert.
Weil nur dann lernst du ordentlich was
und nur dann fällt es dir leicht,
Sachen darin zu lernen.
Und umso besser sind dann auch die Chancen
darin zu arbeiten und umso besser sind
dann auch die Chancen, dort, sagen wir mal,
eine bisschen advancedere Position
auch zu kriegen.
Weil du eben was kannst,
was nicht jeder dahergelaufene
mit Engagement alleine
kommst du auch nicht weiter.
Es gibt sicherlich genug,
also, wenn du keine Ahnung
hast, also das sind die schlimmsten,
seriously, die schlimmsten
Kombinationen an Leuten ist
super motiviert
und keine Ahnung. Das ist die allerschlimmste
Kombination, die es gibt.
Die machen
viel und machen nur Mist.
Das ist quasi
Geldverbrennungsmaschine schlechthin.
Das ist die schlechteste Kombination an Leuten.
Die es gibt.
Du musst wissen, was du machst.
Du musst nicht alles wissen, das sage ich ja auch gar nicht.
Und noch viel wichtiger
für den persönlichen Karriere-Crime
drüber reden, was du tolles gemacht hast.
Vortrag.
Oh.
Hex.
Ist das irgendeine besondere Zahl?
Ne.
61.441
in Dezimal ist das.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
0xf001
Ich mache auch jetzt gleich agiles Bad-Gill.
Genau, da wollte ich
was zu sagen. Zählen für euch
Bonuszahlungen, Beteiligung, Weihnachtsgeld,
Urheinsgeld zum Gehalt für eure
Arbeitszeit. Als Beispiel, ihr habt einen Gehaltswunsch
von 5000 und euch wird
ein Angebot von 4000
gemacht, aber es wird erwähnt, dass ihr im Durchschnitt
auch irgendwer...
Was? Irgendwelche
sonstige Zahlen für die Gewinne...
Ja, wenn das das ist, was ich haben will,
ja, würde ich machen.
Natürlich muss man immer ein bisschen gucken, wie sich das zusammensetzt.
Also, wenn die das jetzt einfach nur sagen
und am Ende des Jahres entschieden wird,
es gibt keinen Bonus, dann natürlich nicht.
Nico, Dankeschön für den Sub, aber
letztendlich ist mir egal, wo die Kohle herkommt,
solange es am Ende des Jahres
unterm Strich dem entspricht, was ich haben will.
Wenn das jetzt alles
nun mal so super vage ist,
dass es auch heißen könnte, nee, gibt es nicht,
dann nicht, aber wenn du ein gewisses
Vertrauen darin hast
und dass die auch eine
nachvollziehbare History haben mit Bonuszahlungen,
dass es die auch wirklich gibt, warum nicht?
Unterm Strich muss das rauskommen,
was du haben willst.
Also, ich habe das auch so gemacht.
Ich habe im Vorstellungsgespräch
einfach mal
riesengroße Zahl gesagt
und da haben sie sich schon angeguckt
und haben gemeint, ah nee, ganz so viel ist es aber nicht.
Und dann haben sie aber gemeint, ja, aber
Moment mal mit Rufbereitschaft
und Bonuszahlungen, dann sind wir
doch in dem Dreh.
Und Rufbereitschaft ist
ganz klar bei uns vertraglich
geregelt, was es dafür gibt und ist auch ganz klar
quasi
garantiert nicht, aber
ganz klar geplant, wie viele
Einheiten du davon quasi bekommst
im Jahr, kannst
du ziemlich genau sagen
und die ziemlich gut im Vorfeld ausrechnen.
Bonus ist auch die letzten Jahre über relativ
ähnlich immer gewesen, außer halt
der persönliche, sogar der ist aber relativ ähnlich.
Und das
hat mir eingeleuchtet, da habe ich gesagt,
okay, passt.
Ich habe absichtlich erst mal richtig
was richtig hohes gesagt.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, was ich gesagt habe.
Ich glaube, ich habe gesagt 115.000 Euro
und da haben sie erst mal gesagt,
das ist zu viel und haben dann aber
rumgerechnet mit Ruf, also es geht um
fünf Tage, nicht um vier Tage Woche, ja,
fünf Tage Woche. Es ist alles immer auf fünf Tage
Woche gerechnet.
Und dann haben sie gesagt, ah, es wäre ein bisschen
viel.
Ja, und dann haben sie mir angefangen
vorzurechnen, dass es aber doch
ganz gut, ganz gut passen würde mit dem
ganzen Bonus und Rufbereitschaft, Zulagen
und so und das ist ja auch schon recht fix und
ja, da habe ich mich dann drauf eingelassen
und ich muss sagen, bis
jetzt stimmt es.
Es ist sogar noch ein bisschen mehr
als das, was sie angekündigt haben, weil
die haben fett Inflationsdings
Ausgleich, Prämie, wie auch immer man das
nennt, Zulage bezahlt.
Ähm
es gibt jetzt noch
eine pauschale Zulage, dass man überhaupt
Rufbereitschaft macht, egal ob man sie
wirklich macht, allein schon, dass man angerufen
werden könnte, kriegt man auch mal eine extra
Zulage. Ich habe letztes
Wochenende Rufbereitschaft gemacht
und das hat, das bringt
ein Wochenende Rufbereitschaft geht bei uns
von Freitagabend
so irgendwie 17, 18 Uhr in dem
Dreh bis Montagmorgen 8 Uhr
das bringt über
1000 Euro brutto.
Nochmal dazu.
Das wird, das ist wirklich
die halbe Lizenz zum Geldtrucken, die
Rufbereitschaft dort und
das kommt, also
es hat sich bisher
alles das bewahrheitet,
was sie mir versprochen haben im Vorstellungsgespräch
sogar noch ein Ticken
mehr. Also ich
finde, wenn das unterm Strich stimmt,
ist alles gut und bis jetzt stimmt es.
Wie oft kommt es zu Einsätzen?
Es kommt
öfters, ne
mach ich nicht. Ich bin Senior
Linux Engineer, also quasi
im Prinzip sowas wie
Server Admin, nur dass es nicht Server Admin
heißt. Ich komme aus dem
DevOps Bereich
allerdings
viele Server Admins nennen sich einfach
DevOps Engineer heute, weil es cooler klingt.
Ist aber trotzdem nicht eins zu eins das
gleiche.
Ich mache hauptsächlich aktuell
Cloud Infrastruktur
Kubernetes und
Automatisierung im Cloud Umfeld.
Hehe.
Wie oft kommt es zu Einsätzen?
Es schwankt.
Es ist aber
so selten, dass ich
immer noch finde, dass es sich lohnt.
Also
nehmen wir mal ein Negativbeispiel. Ich hatte kurz
vor Weihnachten ein Wochenende
Rufbereitschaft. Da wurde ich
Samstag
morgens angerufen.
Dann war ich gerade draußen.
Wir haben eine Stunde,
innerhalb von einer Stunde musst du am Rechner sein.
Und dann habe ich
mit dem was gebastelt, irgendwie eineinhalb Stunden
lang. Samstag morgens
und dann kam
Sonntagnacht das gleiche Wochenende
noch eine Monitoring Meldung,
dass eine Datenbank kaputt ist. Da habe ich mich
tatsächlich vier Uhr nachts eingeloggt,
dann sogar, damals
und habe nachgeguckt
und war der Meinung, das ist ein Monitoring
Fehler, weil da stand,
dass der Monitoring
Agent nicht mehr funktioniert. Ich habe den Agent
neu gestartet, bin in der Pen gegangen,
bis ich dann Sonntag
Mittag nochmal nachgeguckt habe,
weil ich mir gedacht habe, guckst du nochmal?
Und dann ist mir aufgefallen, die Datenbank war
tatsächlich kaputt. Der Check war nur so
suboptimal geschrieben, dass eine kaputte
Datenbank das Monitoring zerstört.
Und ich sage, Datenbank ist nicht verfügbar.
Wird die Arbeitszeit noch extra
vergütet oder ist die Pauschal
weder noch, wenn du
Einsatz hast und arbeitest,
dann bekommst du Zeit gutgeschrieben
und kein Geld.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt schon öfters
gehört, dass manche Leute sagen,
wenn sie am Wochenende
Einsatz haben von zwei Stunden,
dann schreiben sie
den Einsatz gar nicht auf,
weil sie lieber die Kohle haben wollen dafür.
Ist gut,
kann jeder machen, wie er will.
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf
nicht, wie das ist.
Müsste ich eigentlich wissen, weiß ich aber nicht.
Ist nicht,
nee, ist sicherlich nicht legal.
Deswegen macht das ja auch keiner
von uns.
Weil ich weiß gar nicht, ob es
legal ist oder nicht legal ist.
Die Einsatzzeit
als Arbeitszeit, das ist sicherlich
legal alles.
Ob es das nicht aufschreiben legal ist,
keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist.
Wieso, wenn du Einsatz hast, hast du keine
Bereitschaft mehr, ist doch klar.
Wie bist du eigentlich ins
Programmieren gekommen?
Oh, das ist jetzt zu lang die Story.
Erzähl dich im nächsten Stream.
Habe ich sogar schon letztens mal erzählt.
Ach so, ach so.
Nee,
da müsste ich mich ja leaken.
Und wo ich arbeite,
das mache ich bestimmt nicht.
Irgendjemand hat doch eben gerade was
mit zu hoch gefragt, oder?
Ja.
Denkst du, es lohnt sich da mit dem Lohn
so eine richtig hohe Ansage zu machen,
die eigentlich unrealistisch ist?
Allerdings, du musst
selbst nicht
Dice of Cringe machen, wenn du es sagst.
Es muss quasi,
es muss dir innerlich schon wehtun,
ein bisschen, das zu sagen,
aber du musst immer noch sagen können,
okay, ich kann es aber trotzdem
gerade so noch vertreten.
Dann ist es okay.
Ja, aber es lohnt sich, lohnt sich, klar.
Ja, nach der Ausbildung 100k,
das wird wahrscheinlich jedem selbst
einleuchten mit seinem, sagen wir mal,
innerlichen
Cringe-Meter,
dass es halt nicht mehr im Bereich
des nicht mal übertrieben
hohen Realistischen ist.
Aber es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall
immer eine große Zahl zu sagen.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch gar
nichts sagen und fragen, was ist denn
die Gehaltsspanne, weil
das ist ja budgettechnisch sicherlich
relativ, wenn es ein größerer
Laden ist, festgelegt, aber
es schadet
auf jeden Fall nichts.
Weil das,
was ihr sagt, ist oftmals
erstmal die grundsätzliche
Verhandlungsbasis. Bei mir lief es so,
ich habe gesagt, 115k, glaube ich zumindest,
dass ich,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich 110,
ich glaube, ich habe 115, 110 habe ich nicht gesagt.
Ich glaube, ich habe 120,
ich habe 115 gesagt.
So, und
da habe ich mir auch gedacht, okay,
vielleicht busy viel
für das, was sie,
aber dann haben sie gesagt, oh,
okay, passt doch eigentlich
mit den ganzen Zuschlägen.
Und insofern bin ich zufrieden jetzt.
Wie gesagt, auf fünf Tage, nicht
auf vier Tage. Vier Tage kriege ich natürlich
anteilmäßig 20% weniger.
Alles klar, Leute.
Ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Bis die Tage. Macht's gut. See you.